This is Jocko podcast number
one 24 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening
bullets punched through the chopper
as Nev and I jumped out together.
We ran over to the farthest wounded guy,
grabbed him,
ran back and tossed him into the bird.
We picked up a second wounded in action
the same way and then a third amazingly,
without becoming casualties ourselves,
but by the time everyone was
loaded onto the helicopter,
there was no room inside for me.
I stood on the skids and put on my helmet
so I could tell the pilot to take off,
but I found I couldn't talk.
I was so dried out.
My tongue had welded itself to the
roof of my mouth out of pure fear.
I had to open my canteen and drink
some water before I could even gasp.
Let's get this mother out of here.
We took the wounded back to base and
returned to the fight without anything
holding him up.
Now I couldn't out.
Couldn't figure out why Torpy didn't
do something about getting his men
consolidated.
Outside of that Patty,
he still kept saying he was pinned
down. Finally, I lost my temper.
I really chewed his ass over the radio
demanding he get cracking and get those
men out of that Patty.
Now
apparently the next thing he
did was put down the radio,
stand straight up and begin running from
man to man to get them to move back.
He got mowed down right away
and died a short time later.
Maybe I hadn't learned a damn thing at
my con or from Dennis Foley's near miss
in that minefield.
I hadn't asked to stand up.
He didn't need to in order
to extricate himself,
but it hadn't occurred
to me that he would.
I had been playing the game as
if we tend at nap a lot. Natural,
more seasoned leader was in charge.
It was due to the force of my word as
his commander that this inexperienced
young lieutenant was sent to his death
like Jim Gardeners.
Torpys def was a big guilt thing for
me and has remained so all my life
and that he is an excerpt
from the book about face,
which is by Colonel David Hackworth.
A book that we covered on this podcast.
In fact,
it was the first book we covered on this
podcast and there a reason for that.
The book about face was and is my
favorite book and when I was deployed to
Ramadi in 2006 I read it and
reread it every chance I got.
Now the book is about war,
but I have always found it to be a book
about leadership and in my opinion,
the best book I have ever
read about leadership.
David Hackworth,
who was born and raised in California,
lied about his age and joined the
Merchant Marines and served in the South
Pacific and the end of World War II.
And then he joined the army where he
rose through the ranks serving in the
Korean War and the Vietnam War.
Battlefield commissioned
no verse career in combat. He was awarded
two Distinguished Service Crosses,
eight silver stars, three legions of
Merit, distinguished flying cross,
okay.
An eight purple hearts
and
in the end he became an outspoken opponent
of how we were fighting the war in
Vietnam and that cost him
his career in the army.
He went on to write these books and
was able to pass on the lessons that he
learned through these books about face,
which as I said,
we covered on podcast number two.
He also wrote a book called
steal my soldier's heart,
which is covered on podcast 28
and unfortunately he died.
Yeah,
on May 4th,
2005 before I ever got
the chance to meet him,
but a few months ago someone
reached out to me on social media,
someone by the name of Jay Mooka Yama.
Yeah,
and he was a listener to the
podcast and he, he thought,
I'm just might be interested in
talking to his father, James Mooky Amo.
The name looked pretty familiar.
I thought I recognized it and I quickly
realized that this was the full name of
one of the men that appeared in both
books about face and steal my soldier's
heart.
Okay.
The man Colonel Hackworth
simply called milk
did.
I replied to Jay and said,
I would be absolutely honored to be
introduced to his father who was in fact
Major General James and Mooka Yama,
a retired army officer that had served
as a company commander in Vietnam working
directly for Colonel Hackworth.
And after some logistical coordination,
it is my absolute honor to welcome
General James Mooky Yama to the podcast.
Sir,
this is an absolute honor.
Well, Jocko, it,
it is the same on this side and I've
listened to some of your podcasts,
especially the one on steel,
my soldiers hearts and I
couldn't stop listening to it.
And then I realized, I looked at my
watch and I said, this is over two hours.
They're ready.
Uh,
just because of the way you picked out
the really important things that hack,
hack growth. In fact, I forgot
a lot of things until you,
you read verbatim some of
the things that he said and,
and he lived what he wrote.
I might add.
He led by example.
Yeah. Well, I definitely have taken a
ton of lessons from him over the years.
And that's why it's just amazing
to be sitting here with you.
And let's talk about you though.
Let's talk about how you ended up in the
army and where you came from and what
your background was. You know what,
why don't you take us back to Chicago?
Sure. I was born in waste and
the inner city of Chicago,
a neighborhood called Logan Square.
Uh, primarily Polish, German,
Italian. We were the only minority
family in that neighborhood.
We went to a grammar school of 900.
My brother and I were the only minorities.
So I grew up, I grew up basically in a
predominantly white, white environment.
Uh, but I never felt like
I was different really.
Cause everybody treated me fine.
It was,
it was a time in life in the inner
city where everybody knew each other.
You know, in our neighborhood are blocked.
We didn't lock our doors. Um, you know,
everybody knew a, that's
a time when, you know,
most mothers stayed at home
and they were the police of,
of the block. So if anybody would
come by there was out of order, uh,
you know, they would take care of
it. But we, uh, we were, I'd say,
lower middle class economically.
Uh, we never owned a home.
We always lived in an apartment building.
Um,
my father was an immigrant
from Japan. Um, my mother was,
her family was from Japan,
but she was actually born in Madison,
Wisconsin. And so my grandparents
live with us, you know,
we all three generations
in the same apartment. Uh,
and I never felt poor. I, you know,
because we had a strong family.
Uh,
our church was only three blocks
away from our apartment building.
Every Sunday we put on our Sunday best
clothes and we would walk as a family to
church.
No, it's interesting you, you,
you said dad had immigrated from Japan
and your mom was born in Wisconsin. Yeah.
Was your mom not your mom get put in
the internment camps with her family and
during World War II?
No. No, no. Here, here's the thing.
My father came to the states in 1918.
In fact,
that was kind of a
funny thing. He was, uh,
he was going to sign up for World War
One, you know, which was still going on,
but then it ended, so he couldn't,
he couldn't sign up. And, uh,
and then when World War Two
hit, he was too old, you know,
and plus he was a Japanese. He, I
don't know if you know this or not,
Japanese could not become citizens,
naturalized citizens of the
United States until 1952.
And so, uh, so he was, uh, you know,
he was still a Japanese citizen.
Uh, but he was in Chicago. My,
my family was in Chicago, my mother
and father, my brother, I wasn't born.
I was born during World War II.
And so we didn't have to go to camp.
Uh,
mostly the 95% of Japanese Americans at
that time or any one of Japanese descent
live on the west coast in California,
Oregon,
Washington state,
Colorado.
And so when the war hit Pearl Harbor Hit,
uh,
uh, President Roosevelt signed
executive order nine zero six six,
which called for the all people of
Japanese descent to be evacuated from the
west coast and putting concentration
camps in the inner part of the country,
basically in deserted
desert areas. And, uh,
these camps, they euphemistically
referred to them as relocation centers,
but they were really kind of my standard,
you know,
your standard concentration camp with
Bob wire fences with machine guns facing
in not out and people not being
able to come and go as they pleased.
130,000 people of Japanese descent were
put in these camps and two thirds of
them were American citizens,
not aliens.
Okay. And no trials? No, no.
Uh, uh, the only crime that
they had committed was the,
the color of their skin and their fact
that they were of Japanese descent.
And so did your family avoid that
because they were in Chicago?
Yeah, we all need like three or
400 of us in Chicago at the time.
And we weren't considered a threat.
But my other, the rest of my family,
my grandparents on my mother's side
and my cousins and aunts and uncles,
they were all in California
and they all got evacuated.
Just imagine this, you're, it's a Friday
night and you got a knock on your,
okay? It's the local FBI agent
and he says on Monday morning,
be at the corner of Washington and
State Street with two suitcases.
End of communication,
okay. And you, you know,
you don't have time to do hardly
anything. And you, you know,
you go there and then
you're put on a train,
you don't know where you're going and you
wind up in a camp and you're there for
three years. Okay? So let's say you're a,
you're an owner of a small
business. You lose the business, uh,
you no longer have a job,
right?
So he can't pay your mortgage
and things like they lost,
they lost everything. And now you're
18, let's say you're 18 years old,
okay. And this happened
to your family, right?
And the local army recruiter
comes to the camp and says,
I want you to go die for your
country. You know, frankly, Jocko,
I don't know what I would've done.
I might have told the guy to take a walk,
you know,
or
his other words. So many of
them joined up absolutely. The,
the hundreds of of town in the 442nd
regimental combat team. That's right. And,
and those guys fought with incredible
bravery and had some critical battles that
turned some the tied in some
critical situations as well.
Yeah.
They were the most highly
decorated infantry unit and
the history of the United
States army for its size
and time of service.
And there were a regimental combat team,
let's say about 4,500
soldiers because they had, uh,
in an artillery battalion and other
things there were attached. Okay.
In about 18 months of combat,
they were awarded over
9,000 Purple Hearts.
You know, some guys said three or
four, you know, and if not more,
and, uh, you know, present the
presidential unit citation,
you're familiar with that award.
There are Army divisions that
never got that award. Okay.
That regimental combat team was awarded
eight presidential unit citations.
That's unbelievable. Yeah. They
were my personal heroes. So that's,
and that was to kind of get back
to your question and that was, uh,
one of the reasons that I
wanted to join the army.
I was actually going to
ask that. So, you know,
you're sitting here saying if
you were in one of those camps,
you don't know if you would've might've
had to tell him to go take a walk,
but when your time came, you, you, you,
you walked into the recruiter's
office not away from it.
Yeah. Well, uh, in my case, uh,
when I was in high school, uh,
as I told you, uh, you know,
faith is a very strong
part of my whole life.
I've been so blessed in life
beyond anything I deserve.
And, uh, so when I was
our church, you know,
we go to church every Sunday. I was
in the choir, I was in cub scouts,
I was in boy, I was in
the youth group. You know,
all of this was centered around the
church. You know, when I was in scouts,
I went to the national jam
brewery in Valley Forge,
Pennsylvania with 52,000 of my
best friends living in tents and,
but you know,
that was in,
what was the symbol of that jam burry
George Washington at Valley forge,
kneeling in prayer and the motto
of scouting is for God and country.
So that was really my model.
And then I was in a boy's state.
Are you familiar with boys state? No.
Boy State is an American Legion program.
Does that still exist? Yes, yes. And it's,
it's been around probably for 50 years
now and I went, it was a 2050 or, okay,
so it's more than 50 years.
And the concept of boy's state as they
take junior high school juniors ready to
go into senior year and
who are leaders basically.
And they form a quasi state government
for two weeks and they actually divided
into two political parties. They don't
call them Republicans in their requests.
They call him something else. And,
and they have state government,
county government and
local city government.
And you run for offices and you actually
have to come up with a platform and you
debate. And so it's a, it's
a list lesson in civics.
Okay. But it was sponsored
by the American Legion.
So we all lived in like
dorms and the dorms.
We had to make our beds so you could
bounce a quarter on it. You know,
they were all army blankets, stuff
and cots and, but it was wonderful.
It was just a great experience. But, uh,
so when I was in high school, uh, I,
but I was very active in my church,
in my, I'm kind of a driven guy.
And, uh, I was the
president of my, my, uh,
high school youth group
at the church and none,
I became the vice president
of the Chicago Association.
Where did you play sports? No.
Well, I was, uh, no, I didn't.
I was in a, what about your grades?
I was, I was Valedictorian of my,
of my grammar school and high school.
And
they have Valedictorian in grammar school.
That shows you where,
how well I did in grammar school.
I didn't even know that.
And then I, I, uh, I always in the
band, I played clarinet and saxophone,
so I was the first chair clarinet of the
band that was the principal would win
in New York is Straw and, and
so, but anyway, I was, uh,
I was very active in my
church youth group and I,
I was thinking of becoming a minister.
Okay.
But then I was in junior ROTC and Chicago
has the nation's largest junior ROTC
program,
about 30 high schools have it.
And it's a great program. People, j Rotc,
they think it's a feeder for
the military. Okay. I mean,
some of them do go into the military,
but that's not the purpose.
The purpose is to give these high school
students something other than gangs to
belong to the give them experience in
leadership and discipline and teamwork.
And it's, it's a tremendous
program. So I was in junior ROTC
was,
so it's that combined with your,
your view of the,
like the 442nd,
those things are kind of starting to
congeal in your head and maybe move you
towards a military.
Yeah. And then in addition to that, I
have just one sibling, an older brother,
he's about seven years
older than I am. And, uh,
he joined the army as an enlisted guy,
but in the first year of college,
he was in a, a military fraternity
called Pershing rifles. Uh,
which other people like Colin Powell and
some mothers have been including myself
when I went to the u of I. And, uh,
and you have to understand also that
I'm Japanese American in the Japanese
culture,
the warrior,
the Samurai is at the top
of the social strata. Okay.
Unlike China where the scholar
was at the time in Japan,
it's the warrior.
So when I joined the military,
when I became a commissioned officer,
my dad was so proud,
you know, his, his small t shirts
swelled the large, you know,
and when I became a journal,
it's like, you know,
any incredible, but I
you so, so I'm rolling.
Do ROTC in college as well?
Yes.
Oh yes. See, I'm, I'm a driven
guy, right. And, and uh, I was,
here's, here's the thing
though, as I told you,
I was thinking of becoming a minister,
but then I also wanted
to serve in the military.
So what do you think I would do chaplain
perhaps. Exactly. Little problem.
I'm Protestant and my denomination
theologically went so far away from what I
believed in that I couldn't
buy the theology. So now
I'm praying to God. Right.
And I'm saying I get the message, I guess
you want me to do my military thing.
So that's what I did. Okay.
But you fast forward 50 years,
55 years.
What am I doing today?
I'm doing what I wanted to do when I
was in high school cause I have military
outreach USA,
a faith based nonprofit that I started.
So that's a lesson in prayer.
And that is at that time I
thought God was telling me no,
he wasn't telling me
no. He was saying, wait,
it's on my schedule. Not on
your schedule. I mean, you know,
I wasn't enough either as a,
as a military guy,
Norris in my face.
So what year was it that
you're showing up in college?
Uh,
61 I started four years of college.
It's 1965 right.
Vietnam is really not escalated yet.
At that point.
Did you think
it was pretty hot at that time?
And I, I basically, by that time I,
I, I was not in the military
thing. Right, right.
I wasn't going to be a chaplain anymore,
so I was, I was in Persian rifles.
I was under rifle team. I was
on the drill team, you know,
if it smelled military, I always
in, okay. Now yet, give me,
remember I had four years of high school
ROTC also before I went to Benning.
You're pretty good at your drill.
Had, I mean, I mean, infantry,
I OBC infantry officer's basic
course piece of cake. I mean, I,
I went through that. I was an
undergraduate and my class, and in fact,
this is really funny, my class about 200,
you know, brand new second lieutenants,
right.
About a third of it was a national guard
and then about a third were reserves.
And there are only a few of us
that were regular army. See,
I've got a distinguished military graduate
commission, Regular Army Infantry.
Right. And so very few of us
were regular army in my class.
So our attitude was not really the best,
shall we say.
And so we get the Benning and they,
they marched us to class.
I mean this was an, to us it was
insane for second lieutenants. Yeah.
Just tell us where the building
is. We'll get there. Right? No,
we had the march in formation.
So needless to say,
the attitude was not real good with my,
with my company.
So the day we graduated, okay.
They used to have a award,
a streamer that companies could put on
their guide on those called the tiger
tactics award. This was were
really Gung Ho, you know,
companies and all that, which ours
was not needless to say. Well,
the night before we stole from another
company and we put it on our guide on.
So on graduation day, we march by the
headquarters and outcomes, the commander,
the guys live it and you say, where'd
you guys get that? Oh, you know,
it's just appeared
and we were graduating and then what's
the guy going to do to us? Right. So we,
we all graduated and that was it.
So, uh, so 1965, didn't you
go to er, you went to, uh,
you went to graduate school hereafter?
Yeah. Here's the thing. Um,
you know, I told you I had the,
we didn't have a lot of money
for me to go to college,
so I knew I had to earn it myself.
Right.
So when I was in high school,
my senior year,
I worked 33 hours a week.
I worked from five til 10 o'clock at
night at a warehouse in Chicago and I
worked eight hours on, so
I could raise money. Okay.
I also played in two bands. I told
you I played clarinet and saxophone.
I played in a Polish band for,
for weddings.
And that was so cool because by the
third set, everybody was so blasted,
nobody cared.
And then I also played in a Jewish band.
So I used to play for Bar Mitzvahs.
I knew all the temples in Chicago.
I used to tell people I had them coming
or going either way. And then I had to,
you know,
I took out to the government loans and
that's the only way I could afford to go
to school. And so, so 65
rolls around, I graduate
and I find this interesting for a,
for a real obvious reason.
You majored in English in college?
Yeah. The reason I did that Jocko
was once again, you know, I'm,
I'm pretty focused guy in my,
my focus was on becoming the best officer.
I could be the best leader I
could be of infantry soldiers.
And I knew I was going into combat,
right?
So as a freshmen I tried to determine
what am I going to major in to prepare me
for that.
So I looked at psychology
and I looked at English,
not rhetoric, but
English literature. Okay.
I rejected psychology and my first year,
because we had these classes,
classes with Pavlov and his dogs
and all this stuff, you know,
and I'm going through that and I said,
what does this have to do at people?
You know? I mean I want to learn how
to, you know, work with people, well,
literature, whether you read the
whole continuum of, you know,
every man, your Shakespeare or
Hemingway, if you read that stuff,
there are universal traits of human
nature, they'd come out at you. Okay.
If you can understand that, you can
realize what motivates people. Okay.
So I,
and then not only that,
but if you read the best
writers of all time,
I just felt by sure osmosis gun,
not the smartest guy,
just by sure Osmosis,
you know,
I could absorb that and I
could express myself better.
So that's why I majored in English.
I've talked about that. I was, I was
an English major as well. I was, I was,
I was prior enlisted,
so I had been in for eight years and
actually I'd been in for 10 years by the
time I went to college and I knew right
away I was going to be an English major.
And the reason I wanted to be
an English major, because I had,
I'd gotten commissioned
and serve two years in the,
in the seals before I went to college.
As an officer and I realized
you got to write everything.
You got to read directives from people
and got to understand what they're saying
and then you're going to
communicate with your troops.
And I wanted to have a good command
of the English language. The,
the part that you talked about,
the understanding of human nature was
something that I saw once I got in and I
started reading it.
It's an art start applying and
thinking about when I was reading it.
Now this is something that I,
that I advocate for everyone to,
if you want to really understand
human nature, got to read.
Yeah. Yeah. So I was, so, I was,
you know,
when I said that in 1965 the war,
cause what was it, what year was I
drank? 19 that was 1965 wasn't it?
The Battle of I drank, I
think it was, I think you're,
I think it was 1965 I think it was.
And you know,
they kind of use that as, hey, this
is when the real escalation started.
And,
and the reason I asked
you that specifically is
because I've had some Vietnam
vets on that we're going to
college in 1965 and they were like,
they didn't even hadn't even
heard of Vietnam at that point.
So I guess it was because I was in ROTC.
You know how it's kind of paying
more attention. Yeah. You know,
and I knew I was going to Benny.
I mean that was a foregone conclusion.
And you knew you were going to combat
as well. Oh yeah. That was your mind.
Well, I, yeah, cause that was my goal.
Yeah. Be An infantry officer and you know,
if I, you know, that's, that
to me was where I wanted to go.
And S and so in 65 I got an,
I got an offer to get an
assistantship, uh, you know, to,
to be, uh, really a counselor in the dorm,
but it's like I died and
went to heaven because they,
they paid for tuition and fees and
I got like 100 bucks a month salary,
which to me was like
richest guy in the world.
But the important thing was I could get
my master's degree. Okay. And by the way,
I got it in a year because I
went to summer school. I, I just,
I'm wanting to go on active duty, but
this was a chance for me to go, you know,
under the assistant ship
and not have to pay for it.
But now the pragmatism kicks in
for me, you know, cause you know,
we leave with an English degree
is, you know, you know, it's,
it's great for preparing
you to understand things,
but you know,
that and 50 cents in those
days we get me a cup of coffee.
So I,
and then I knew I was going to go into
combat and I knew I was going to be an
infantry officer in the odds of my,
perhaps getting wounded, you
know, we're fairly decent,
so I need to have a fallback, you
know, and I wasn't an accountant,
so I wasn't a CPA or you know,
something like that.
So I got my master's in the
teaching of social studies,
so I could be a teacher and you know,
you don't have to run the hundred yard
dash to be a teacher. And so, and I,
and teaching as a noble profession
and I always felt that, um,
you know,
it's something I could do if I got wounded
and still contribute to society and
70 well,
you know,
the 75% of your time is an
officer or senior NCO is teaching,
you know. So I figured I want
to find out how the pros do it.
Allegedly what I found out is the military
has the best education system really
does.
You know,
I didn't have to get my master's degree
in history and philosophy of education
and ed psych and all that
stuff. No, didn't need it.
So you, you wrap up, you get your
master's degree and now you, you know,
you're going to Vietnam. What, what
happens is that when you graduate.
Okay. So I, I go to Fort Benny,
I go to Iop, see, and you know,
I'm an undergraduate and my class,
so I didn't finish that story. This,
my my like class that I was in, you
know, really bad attitudes guys.
Right. On the day of graduation, they
announced the honor graduates. Okay.
I was in the third platoon.
So first platoon they announced
the undergraduates in the platoon,
second platoon, they announced the
undergraduates third platoon, which I am.
Then I'm the only guy who,
an undergraduate out of my platoon,
when they announced my name,
everybody boots
because I ruined our record. Right.
So what happened is I volunteered for,
I volunteered for a while. I was regular
army, so I had the, I had to go airborne.
I volunteered for ranger school,
but in those days,
the West pointers all was mandatory.
They had to go to ranger school.
So I graduated at the same time
that the west pointers did.
They took up all the quotas. So I didn't
have, I couldn't get into ranger school,
but I had a solution. See, I'm always
thinking ahead. I was going to,
I applied for pathfinders school,
so I figured I'd go through pathline
your school, I'd finished that.
The West pointers would be gone. I could
slide into the next ranger class. Right.
They didn't give me Pathfinder, so
now I'm stuck. Right. So I said, okay,
I'm volunteering from Vietnam
and they sent me to Korea.
So I was in the DMZ in Korea,
which is really a god thing. I,
I've got to tell you this because I was
putting a second id on the DMC and those
days you were, you were assigned and you
stayed there for 13 months on the DMZ
and there was still active combat
patrolling and take casualties.
Yeah.
13 months I was there,
we had 12 Kia in about 40 wounded.
Okay. So this was not a walk
in the park. And uh, it was,
it was a great experience for me because
in addition to see, we were in the DMZ,
we actually had a company compound.
Okay.
And we actually had our guard mount,
you know,
and we had our own NCO club and we
had, and, and so we had all the,
all the bs of the admin stuff that
you do on when you're in garrison.
But we are doing combat
patrolling every day on the DMZ.
So it was really a,
a great experience for me as a young
officer because I was able to lead troops
out on patrol.
But also I had to do all this admin stuff,
you know,
the garrison.
And so that was your platoon commander
tour. What were the patrols like?
Where were you doing?
Um,
basically they were ambushed patrols
because the DMZ was set up where it was a
free fire zone.
If you saw anyone you could shoot him
cause nobody was supposed to be there.
Okay. And we would have
to say a Korean Chung, he,
which is tell him to stop,
you know,
but how many times would you say debt
before you pulled the trigger? Basically.
But we,
we did ambush patrolling primarily.
And that was,
you said you were lucky you were,
you said it was God
that put you there and,
and do you feel that because that's
just a really good sort of warm up for
combat? Absolutely. Absolutely.
I feel that way. My first
appointment to Iraq was,
was relatively,
it was relatively easy,
right? We were in, in Baghdad,
things were going pretty well.
We had the upper hand on the enemy and
we didn't get into too much major combat.
You know, we've gotten a few
firefights here and there,
but wasn't like when I got from Adi and
I felt like that I was really blessed to
have had an experience where you get the
kind of the initial nervousness out of
your system and you realize, okay,
I can do this. That, that was,
I felt pretty lucky about that.
Well, also, you know, keep in mind,
I was just a young second lieutenant
shave tale. What did I know really?
And I was once again, blessed, I
had a platoon sergeant who really,
he was a Korean War veteran guy
was actually in east seven. Okay.
And, and basically when I got there,
you know, I was his lieutenant.
Okay. So nobody screwed around
with me. But on the other hand,
I listen real carefully. I mean
I, that's one thing I learned.
You know, I as a young officer, uh,
I've had my success in the military
because I had great and CEO's who made me
look good and I had commanders
who mentored me and didn't
cut my head off when I
screwed up.
And I've made my fair share of mistakes.
You get done with that tour. And then
what's your, what's your next assignment?
So,
you know,
you get your dream sheet right a lot
where you want to go when you do her off,
so when you leave that area.
And so I put it in for Fort Bragg,
for Fort Benning, cause I want to go
to an airborne unit cause I was urban,
but I had never served in an airborne
unit. Right. They sent me to Fort Lewis,
Washington. So I go to Fort
Lewis, Washington to the,
uh, uh, the training center,
infantry training center. Okay.
And when I get there,
I made a long story short,
when I was in Korea, uh, I also was, uh,
they found out I had a master's degree,
so they pulled me off the line.
And, uh, the battalion commander
calls me into his office, right? So I,
I go down there and he says,
uh, Lieutenant Mccoy Yama, uh,
how you doing sir? I'm having
a great time. You know, I'm,
I'm with soldiers, you know, we're
doing combat patrolling, you know,
and I really, this is what I've
been trained to do, you know,
and, and he's so I'm
happy. Okay. So he says,
I see you have a master's. I
said, yes, sir. And he said,
you know,
our battalion adjutant is leaving
and you have a degree in English,
you can see where this is
all going, right? And I said,
yes, sir. And he said, well,
how would you like to be the
battalion adjutant? And I said, sir,
I'm honored that you would even consider
this, but you know, I'm really happy,
you know, leading soldiers.
And he said, lieutenant,
I'm not looking for
happiness in my battalion.
You will report on Monday
morning. Yes sir. Okay,
so off I went and, uh, and I
became the battalion out unit.
But that once again was a great
experience for me cause I,
I learned a lot of the admin
stuff and unfortunately,
and some I also saw some bad stuff
going on, which I was not happy with.
I saw, you know, I, because
I was the ad unit. Oh,
what I didn't tell you was
that was that battalion level.
The brigade unit left and they called
me up to brigade to be the brigade.
Now I'm a first lieutenant
that's a majors position. Right.
But I happen to be pretty obvious the
best battalion they had, you know,
not all the Italians.
So I go up there,
I go up there to brigade
to be the brigade ad unit.
And what I found was,
you know,
the officer efficiency
reports and the Oers,
I knew all the battalion
commanders because I dealt
with them all. Okay. So if,
if I,
Jim Mccoy Yama were to rate the battalion
commander's based on their leadership.
Right. And I would have rated
them one, two, three, four. Okay.
But I saw the reports going through
in was four, three, two, one.
And, and, and that's because
they were looking for managers,
not commanders.
And so that was a,
that was a tough pill to swallow.
So
eyeopening for you as a young,
yeah. I know when I worked for,
I was the admiral's aid.
I saw,
I didn't see stuff like that that
turned me off, but I saw it just,
just getting a better grip on what was
happening behind the scenes was very
important for me and helped me
out, you know, later on. Um,
and when you were in Fort Lewis, that's
when you first met Hackworth, right?
Absolutely. Quick. This was so cool.
When I'm in when hand, now I'm a
captain by this time I'm a captain.
Right.
And I met the under
secretary general of the SDS.
Uh, I was the secretary,
the general staff. Okay.
What that means is I was the assistant
for the chief of staff, basically.
And so I,
yeah. Do you know who Hackworth was? We
all, we all, I mean hack was a legend.
You know, everybody knew who he was.
But also because I had that job,
one of my functions was always the guy
who coordinated the general schedule and
the chief to staff schedule and Hackworth
was reporting into Fort Lewis as a new
battalion commander. Okay. Well whenever
a new battalion commander came in,
I always did research on the person,
you know, so I could tell the general,
you know, here's the guy who's coming,
here's his background. Well halfers was,
you know,
Mister infantry basically.
And so when he came to see the general,
he walks into the headquarters, you know,
I'm sitting behind his desk, he walks
in, so I stand up, you know, I say,
welcome Colonel Hackworth to Fort Lewis.
You know,
the general will be with
you in 10 minutes. You know,
cause he came early, right?
The first words out of Hackworth
smile. I'm not kidding. First words,
what do you doing? Sitting behind a
desk? He said, you should have a company.
You said, if you want one,
I'll give it to you. Okay.
The guy doesn't know me from Adam.
Right. I mean, you know, and,
but you know, I was pretty sharp in
the way a warmer uniform. I did have,
you know, my jump wings and my ear, I
have an expert infantryman's badge. Okay.
Uh, and I had my EIB and that's
it. I didn't wear any ribbons,
radar stuff and just the stuff
that counted as far as I was.
And so hacks on that, you
know, and, and I said, colonel,
I really appreciate,
you know what you're saying,
but I came to the same conclusion that
you did a couple months ago and I've
already talked to a battalion commander
who's accepted me to take one of his
companies. So I'm committed to
him, sir. So I can't, you know,
I'd love to take you up on your offer,
but I can't because I committed to the
southern battalion commander and hacks
that I understand. Totally. Okay,
well that turned out to be another God
thing because later on, as you know,
in the book, he and I got together and
we saved the career of a drill sergeant
[inaudible].
I just want to hear a little bit more
about this because it's something that I
haven't been able to gather from
anyone, you know, in my mind,
you know, I thought everyone must
look at hack, like, you know,
this guy's Mr infantry as you put it.
But I also would say to myself, well,
you know,
here's what I'm thinking that because he
wrote these books and because I studied
him,
but that was an actual thing.
People knew who he was by his
reputation throughout the army.
Yeah. It was not only its reputation,
but his appearance. I mean, uh,
you know, his neck was probably the size
of my waist. I mean, this, you know,
a Hackworth was just, you know,
and he always had, you know,
he wasn't bald like today, you know,
but, uh, you know, eighth of an inch,
you know, razor sharp, you
know, sides and all that.
And what I didn't say is when he Hackworth
had this unique ability size people
up when he saw them, like
when he said that to me, and,
and I've said this
before, but hackers, uh,
his philosophy was you're either a
dud or a stud and there was nothing in
between. And he had
this uncanny, I've seen,
I've seen it dozens of times where he
actually did size guys up and I never saw
him miss on that evaluation.
He just had this,
this instinct, you know, to
CISE guys up. And that's,
and that's why he was successful as a
commander because one of the principles is
to surround yourself with good people.
And so when he came to a unit and he
found some guys that weren't cutting it,
they were gone. I mean, especially in
combat, you know, he can't tolerate that,
you know, and he would, and he had
the strings that he could pull and
he had the relationships all over the
place it seems. That's right. Now how did,
when did he leave with two to go to
Vietnam and take over the battalion?
He probably let the,
see I left in May of 69,
so it was probably end
of 68 or maybe early 69.
And, and he goes over and he's over there
for a few months and then he ends up
needing, while he wants to surround
himself with good people again.
And so he reaches out to you? Yeah.
How does it, how does that happen?
Well, uh, you know, I,
I was still at Lewis as an ait
company commander and, and,
and another thing I should
tell you at that time,
and I'm not real happy with the army
because they never gave me any assignment
or anything I ever asked for four at
this point. Are you ready for this?
I,
I get what I didn't tell you was in
graduate school I majored in Japanese
history and Chinese history and
political science and Japanese language,
uh, in my master's of
social studies. Okay.
And I happened to be Japanese American.
I haven't had a tour in Korea.
Right. Where, by the way,
I didn't tell you I got some
awards from the Korean army.
And so now the army comes out with the
foreign area specialty training program
or fast. Okay. And the concept
was a great concept. You know,
in Vietnam he got caught
with our pants down,
cause we don't have any army experts
in Vietnam. Nobody knew the culture,
nobody knew the language,
the politics sound familiar.
And so basically the army said,
okay,
we're going to develop geographic
experts for the whole world.
Okay. And we're going to
call it the fast program.
So I saw that and it was in the
army times, you know, and they said,
if you have an interest
called this number, you know,
and so I called, you know,
and he said, hey look, pull up my record.
You know, you'll see. You know, I'm, I'm,
I got my master's degree and
fiery student affairs. Ethnically,
I'm Japanese,
I've got her a tour in Korea where I
got some awards from the Korean army.
Okay. And I'm regular army. Right.
What are my chances of getting in this
program that we should be 100% right.
Are you ready for this?
The first words out of your guy's mouth,
you haven't been to Vietnam.
And I said, well, that's right,
but if you'll go back in my record,
you'll see I volunteered for Vietnam
in the army, sent me to Korea. Okay.
You said, but that doesn't count.
Okay. The second thing he said was,
you haven't been a career course advanced
course or officers. So he got me there.
I hadn't, you know, I was
just a young camp and I hadn't
been there. So in essence,
he was telling me,
you know,
come back in a couple of years and
maybe we'll think about it. You know,
he didn't give me any
encouragement. He didn't say, Hey,
you're a natural for this program. You
know, I'll keep on monitoring your career.
You know, he didn't do
any of that stuff. Okay.
And about that time I got the letter
from Hackworth saying, hey, Mukai can,
if we got a war going on, if you
want a company, it's yours. And like,
I hit the lotto, you know,
and I, and frankly I was, I
was sneaking of, you know,
resigning my regular army commission,
but I hadn't been to Vietnam yet.
And Alyssa Bachelor,
I had a lot of my friends who were married
who are going back for their second
and third tours, you know, and I felt an
oblique and not only that, but I figured,
well, maybe if I go, I'll
change my mind, you know,
and serving under Hackworth who would
be the best opportunity I could,
I could have. So I jumped at it,
you know, and I went, but, uh,
things did not.
Right.
How did you get orders?
I mean, do you know,
I know Hackworth had some
relationships with people,
but just to get a guide deployed to
be in his battalion, how did you pull,
how do you pull that off?
What did it look like?
Well, I mean, I, I called my
infantry officer assignment guy,
whom I never spoken to in the five
years I was on active duty. Right.
Cause I always felt that I
shouldn't be managing my own career.
You know, if I, if I did my job
that the army would, you know, I,
I be treated okay. You know
what, none of that ever happened.
So I called this guy at the
Pentagon and I say, Hey,
I'm volunteering for Vietnam again.
And he basically said,
well, okay, you know, give me your phone
number in case we lose connection here.
And, and then he said, and I
said, but I have a stipulation,
I need to go to the ninth division. And
he said, okay, I can make that happen.
When do you want to go? I said, as
soon as possible. This is February.
And he said, well, I can get you
there in August. And I said, no,
that's not soon enough. He said,
how about April? I said, sold.
So I got orders to, you know, now
everybody told me in the world at that,
here I am, uh, infantry,
regular army captain going to
Vietnam. When I hit the Rep. Oh, devo.
Uh, they could assign me anywhere. You
know, orders meant nothing. You know,
it because captain, it's infantry.
Captain's wear a diamond dozen.
So when I get to Vietnam,
everything was greased.
Ninth Division.
I went from the night I went from,
from Saigon, right to the ninth
division at Dong Tam. You know,
I had land there, I got my orders
to his battalion. It's all right.
All Greece weren't,
you're doing some kind of like Vietnam
indoctrination for a week long and hack
pulled you out two days into
it or something like that.
I have saw upset, they had a five day, uh,
in country training program for
newbies. Okay. Especially, you know,
well, you know, in the Delta, uh,
I'd say 85% of our casualties for,
from booby traps. And so we
were, and there was a special,
a terrain, you know, with
uh, rice patties and,
and canals and you know, just the
whole thing was totally different.
And so they had this five day training
course to acclimate you and to understand
the booby traps and the
terrain and all this stuff.
And I'm in a for two days and I'm pulled
out of the course and I'm put on a
helicopter and they take me down
to the battalion fire support base.
And I mattered in a wet hand,
you know, and I, I go to half
and I say, sir, you know,
how can you do this to me?
I mean, I'm trying to learn
how to stay alive, you know,
it's like, and he said, look, you don't
need that stuff. I know you, you know?
Yes sir.
And when you showed up,
so for those that hadn't read,
having read the books or listened
to the other podcasts about this,
Hackworth had showed up.
He was requested by name to go and
take over the four 39th in Vietnam,
which was a pro was, which was a battalion
that was having a lot of problems.
And he went in there and he
fixed it. I mean, that's,
there's no simple way to put it.
He went in there and,
and squared that battalion weigh in and
made them from hopeless to hardcore. Is,
is the,
the terms that get used when you showed
up that he'd already been there for a
while.
So things were pretty solid at that.
Oh, they were, they were so
good. It was incredible. In fact,
the first guy I met when I,
when I got there was our battalion s four,
his name was Mario Takahashi.
He was actually a, uh,
a national guard guy from Hawaii.
You Eve is about six, two or six,
three big Japanese guy.
You know,
Nia was Hackworth,
Hackworth that could you just,
you made it sound what you said,
look, talking about his neck.
Was he like a big coffee in pictures?
He always looks pretty lean and,
and not very physically large. Wow. Well,
when I, I mean, he was stoked.
Okay. I mean, he wasn't,
he wasn't real huge. He
wasn't real tall. Uh,
but just the way he carried himself,
that's what I always was.
He was just a guy that if you walked
away and go, I bet that, you know,
how tall was Hackworth with o six.
Eight. Yeah. To find out is whatever,
five dinners. And not only that,
but I'll tell you, he went,
when I became a general, later on in
life and, and he came to one of my, uh,
every, every year, I used to have
a leadership conference for my,
my officers and my Nco said I would
invite speakers to come to and Hackworth
came, uh, to one of my conferences.
And then he visited me in Chicago
when he was doing his, uh,
about face book.
Right.
And so he invited me and my wife and
kids to have dinner with him one night.
You know, he always said, bring your kids,
you know, some guys would say, no, just,
you know,
being your wife or whatever,
because like kids were fairly
young then weren't real young.
They were maybe eight or
nine, you know, at that time.
And my wife and the kids
actually commented about how
soft spoken ham worth was.
He wasn't a blustery
guy. Uh, uh, you know,
among guys. Yeah. But you know,
in the, in public with, you know,
women and family members,
he was, he was, uh,
a gentleman, which kind of surprised my
wife cause I had told him what I'm about,
you know. And so, but
that's, that's how he was.
And, and so the, the battalion,
when you show up, it's just the guys are
really on board with what's going on. Oh,
absolutely.
Because I got there probably
three weeks before our famous,
uh,
it wants me to be a battle on 22 may
where we decimated a VC training battalion
basically. Uh, and, uh, I mean,
I remember being at the talk,
you know, when he's planning,
while this Hackworth had
this innate quality get,
just smell out the enemy. You know,
even with all the intelligence,
we get all of this stuff,
you know,
he was able to figure out what
they were doing. And so he,
he set us up for that night. But to
answer to you address what you are saying,
by the time I got there,
Takahashi was the first guy I met.
He was really a s a strong straight you.
And he was the s four.
And so he got all the equipment for the
battalion and he got it whatever way he
had to get it,
you know,
and then I meet the next guy I meet
is another is a company commander.
And the guy was like six,
three or something, you know.
So I'm seeing a pattern here right
now and I'm five foot five. Okay.
But here's the cool thing about this.
One of the other company commanders,
his name was Don Meyer.
And by the way,
Hackworth had this really cool way of,
of uh,
using words and terms and titles
that you'll life our companies.
We're not Alpha Bravo, Charlie
Delta. They were alert,
battle clean more in dagger.
Okay.
And the claim,
or a company commander was
a guy by name of Don Myers.
Don Meyers was my roommate in college at
the University of Illinois and we both
were infantry ROTC guys,
right? And then later he was,
he was with the hundred and
first and he was wounded.
So they shipped him to Fitzsimmons and
then they assigned him to Fort Lewis,
which was where Hackworth and I were.
So Donna and I were roommates again
if Fort Lewis Washington. Okay.
So then half were ships to Vietnam
and he takes Meyers with him.
Okay. So Noel Meyers, who by the
way is six foot three. Right.
And his nickname was lank. And when
he and I were in college as roommates,
it was like Mutt and Jeff, you
know, and I wasn't that tall guy.
And so anyway, uh, but as you,
as you can understand to have,
I commanded battled company and he come
in to claim our company and I knew that
if we were going to run into any
cramp, you know, that he would,
he would be there for me and he
knew I would be there for him.
And that was, that was it
just, it was really good.
Yeah.
That,
that whole thing with names is something
that I completely ripped off from
Hackworth. When I was a task unit
commander, our tasking, it was called,
whether it was Alpha Bravo
and Charlie and I had bravo.
And immediately when I took it over,
I changed the name from Bravo
to bruiser and that's was,
that changed the attitude of people.
It really does.
So as you know,
all elite units have,
have greetings and chondricytes.
Right.
So for the hardcore are, our
motto was hardcore, we Condo,
that was what the reading was.
The countersign,
which I cannot say totally
was no effing slack.
Okay. But I'll tell you, there were
a guy, I saw this eye witnesses,
there were guys who were wounded on
stretchers and Hackworth would walk up to
them and Nate salute him
and say hardcore Econdo
what kind of missions did you do
when you showed up there? So you're,
you take over your company commander.
Yeah, there were, they
were, they were Pramod. Uh,
they were just really a [inaudible]
search search and destroy.
Not really destroyed, but sir,
we were seeking out the VC.
Uh, but as it got closer
to, we knew we were leaving.
Right because President Nixon
had had said that, you know,
so it just got to be, you know, we
candy or you make sure they weren't,
if they were there,
we get into firefights if it didn't happen
very often because most mostly booby
traps and things. Uh, and uh,
basically that was it. I
mean, cause they, you know,
they're smart. They knew we were leaving.
So why going while you get into contact,
right. You're leaving now. You, you
were showing me some pictures earlier.
You're pretty famous picture
that got published. It's someone,
uh, your, your Rto had just been
wounded. What was the story?
Yeah,
this was one of our operations and there
was a booby trap then and he was a,
he got a sucking chest wound from it then.
And I got a little shrapnel, not a lot.
And uh,
uh,
basically I called in a medevac
helicopter and the helicopter came in.
Unbeknownst to us,
there was a UPI photographer on the
helicopter and he snapped a picture of my
guys carrying my wounded Rto on a
stretcher towards the helicopter.
And that became like the UPI picture
for the day, the one around the world.
And you know,
the Vietnam photograph,
I didn't even know it existed
until three years later. I was out,
I was off of active duty.
I was reading on US News and World
Report magazine and the picture was like
three inches by four inches
in the magazine. But it was
all my soldiers, you know,
and I saw it and they said, hey,
and then I saw I was in the picture,
so I'm kind of in the picture
so you can see me. So, uh,
I got the photo from,
from them.
I get asked a lot and it's something
that I don't have any experience with is
what it was like having draftees.
As you know,
I was in all of the all volunteer military
and then on top of that, you know,
the unit I worked with, we were
all volunteered again. You know,
you volunteered to come in,
then you volunteer again to
try and be in the seal teams.
And people ask what it was
like working with draftees.
Now Hackworth opinion was draftees were
good because they didn't care about
their career. And if they thought
something was wrong, they'd say, hey,
this is crap. We don't want to do that. Or
Hey, you're not telling the truth to us.
And so he thought it was good
and it kept the army in check.
But there's still had to be
some leadership differences
in dealing with an end
later. In your career,
obviously you started working
with the all volunteer army.
What did you notice about the
draftees that you learned from?
Well, the draft, these just like,
and it doesn't make any difference
for your draftees or, or volunteers.
It depends on the leadership and you know,
they'll respond the good leadership and,
uh,
the, the draftees were like anyone
else. Once you're in the position,
you're going to do the best you can,
especially when you're in Colombia
because you want to survive. And, and,
and by that time it gets to
be a bonding thing. You know,
you're not there fighting for liberty
and justice and the American way.
You're fighting for the guy to the right
view and the guy to the left of you
basically. Cause you go every day you're
living together, you're dying together,
you know?
And so it's,
it's a function of leadership and
of draftees were great guys. I mean,
I serve with them
anywhere. Uh, I, in fact,
I didn't even know who is straight
and I didn't care. I didn't ask,
you know whether they're
draftees are volunteers,
although the vast majority of
our guys who were draftees in,
in the fourth year to 39th wow.
And that's why it was so cool about it
that Hackworth could take that battalion
and turned it around. Mna heard stories
cause I came later on, you know,
but he had a price on his head initially.
Yeah.
Price on his head from his own guy.
Well yeah,
but nobody had the gonads
to step up and claim no.
Clean the price so to speak.
Yeah.
I mean one of the things he talks about,
and again,
I've talked about this on other podcasts,
but you know, when he showed up,
everyone had whatever they had guitars
and they had radios and they had,
you know, big hammocks for themselves
and, and he got there and said, okay,
anything that you can't carry on your
back is going to be in the middle of our
base tomorrow morning.
It's getting shipped out on helicopters.
So people went crazy.
Are you kidding me?
Well, not only Dan, you know what
he did, and I'm sure you know this,
but he took away class Emile's Oh,
I did not know that.
Or I don't remember it because
they were so, they were so, uh,
uh, how to say this nicely. They,
they were not disciplined. Okay.
Cause they had lousy
leadership before that.
And a Hackworth basically said,
you know,
you guys are soldiers and he said,
I'm going to keep you alive, you know,
but you're going to have to soldier. So
he actually took classes away initially.
He made them shine their
boots. I mean, you know, stuff,
this sounds crazy, you know, but he
was getting their attention. Yeah.
You know, and, and cleaning weapons.
I mean, they would, you know,
they were not cleaning. I
mean, how crazy is that?
They weren't cleaning their weapons at
nighttime. There was a night discipline,
like discipline was almost
nonexistent. I mean, it was crazy.
And Hackworth made them, you
know, soldier up and, and, uh,
but then what happened was they started
to use his tactics and they found out
that, hey, this works. I mean, we're not
taking casualties. Like we did before,
we're actually inflicting casualties
that we weren't doing before.
And then he started to give stuff
back in or anyone else he did,
he took away beer.
Beer was like water,
you know, the average temperature was
like 95 degrees, you know, and all that.
And it was like 3.2 whatever the beer was,
you know?
But he took that away initially too.
And people thought he was nuts.
Yeah. Actually there's a great quote
about face at some guy writing home to as,
this is a quote from a letter somebody
wrote down road, you know, my new car,
my new battalion commanders crazy.
I don't know what's going to happen.
That's literally a letter a guy ride home.
It's interesting to me.
So I've seen this, and I'm sure
you've seen this in your career,
I've seen it in the business world.
I'm sure you've seen in the business
world and in the military guys that go so
far in that direction of being so
hardcore and over the top that they break
their guys and people actually don't
like them and they don't want to serve
them. And they don't want to do
a good job because they're there,
they're too focused on stuff that doesn't
really matter. And Hackworth just,
he seemed to have this ability to balance
it so well between being hardcore.
And yet at the same time,
everybody knows that he's going to
take care of him and he loves them.
Yeah. That, that was the main thing
because they knew that they were going,
they were going to live under his
command if they followed what he said.
And there would be successful too.
Don't forget that success breeds success.
And so the hardcore is as
they kept on progressing,
became prouder and prouder
of, you know, and the guys,
it was just the,
a unit that nobody wanted it to
reckon with it. And that's how it was.
But has led by example. I can't, I
just can't emphasize that enough.
Uh,
you know,
I have my leadership mantra,
which,
uh, and I'm a simple guy, so I boils,
boil things down simply and
the three words, example,
caring and balance. And you got to
lead by personal example. It's not,
you know, do what I say, but do what I do.
And caring is to care for your soldiers.
Uh,
and you know, caring means,
especially in combat,
keeping them alive, that's how you
care for him. And you train tough,
you know, I mean, Hackworth
always mentioned that, you
know, the harder you train,
you know, the, the better, the delt
performing kind of invent. And in fact,
sometimes it was easier in combat then,
you know, some of the training did,
he'd make them go through and,
and finally his balance to especially
leaders. And I'm talking to leaders,
right?
And I always told my leaders that you've
got to maintain a balance between your
professional military job and your family.
And I used to tell my guy,
if you're not doing me any good,
if you're going through a divorce,
you know, and too many guys,
it's easy when you get promoted to get
kind of caught up in the perks and then
the responsibility, you know, so you
work harder to be more. And then when,
what do you do? You ignore your family
and then things fall apart. And,
uh, so I, I warned my, my
soldiers, I always said, you know,
maintain that balance. And I tried to
do that, not only personally but the,
to get my [inaudible] when we were
mobilized, for example, k my division now,
this was not, we didn't deploy
overseas. We were a training division.
Our war time mission was the
army reserves, by the way,
was the only service that had this.
We,
we had reservist who's wartime mission
was to take over the training of the
recruits at the active duty stations,
which would then release those active
duty soldiers to go join forces and made a
lot of sense. You know, so,
so, uh, when that happened,
uh, I, I went to my staff,
now you have to understand this is
like the late eighties, right? Okay.
And I went to my staff and I said,
I want a 24 hour,
800 number from my family support program.
I want my soldiers to know,
and I want their spouses to know
that while they're deployed,
if there's any problems,
they can count on us.
And I want it to be 24, seven
man. And he said, general,
when you have to understand those days,
800 numbers were pretty expensive. And,
and, and they said, you know, number one
is going to be expensive. Number two,
you know, 24 seven you know,
and I said make it happen.
Cause I,
I,
the last thing I wanted my soldiers who
were deployed to worry about was their
families. Right now none.
What I did is I, yeah,
I had the two star stationary,
you know, as, as a major general,
a little notes.
You know,
they're not eight and a half
by 11 their little note things.
So I told my staff I want to send a
personally signed note to every spouse or
significant other of a deployed soldier
in this division and I'm on a note to go
to their employer because you have to
understand these are reservists, right?
Okay.
So I had 1500 soldiers mobilized,
right? So this is 3000 letters
that I'm going to sign. You know,
personally they wanted me
to use an auto auto pen.
You don't buy it by computer
manufacturer, your signature. I said,
no way. These are, these are
going, you know, so I, I did that.
And what happened was I was,
I had a cousin who's husband
was a steel seal salesman.
Okay.
And she calls me one day and she said,
you'll never know what
happened to my husband.
He was making a call on
this company in Indiana.
Okay.
And on the wall was one of my letters
to them and he saw my name on it,
you know.
So caring for your caring
and balance is important.
Um,
you know,
you talked about
that,
that operation that was so well
planned and so well executed.
And you talked about hack words,
sort of sixth sense instinct.
Um,
and then, you know, I've,
I've heard you talk in some
other interviews about a
situation that you were in
that was,
that you described as really
sort of impacting your,
your mental state.
And to me when I heard you talk about it,
it seemed to be almost like
a turning point mentally,
psychologically for you.
And it had to do with you overrunning a
position and you end up with some, some,
yeah, I didn't, I didn't realize the
impact of that incident until many,
many years later.
But in order for me to explain that,
I have to talk about
something called moral injury,
which is an when the so called
invisible wounds of war. Uh,
a lot of people are familiar with
post traumatic stress disorder.
A lot of people are aware
of traumatic brain injury,
but when you ask them if
they could describe the
invisible wounds of war called
moral injury, very few people
are, are knowledgeable about that.
How long has that term been used?
Uh, there was a, a, a psychiatrist
at the Va doctor, Jonathan Shay,
who, uh, basically, uh,
coined that phrase in 2009.
So it's been around for a while and now
it's starting to really pick up steam in
research because of the,
its significance in contributing to
the high suicide rate among veterans.
And,
uh,
the concept is when I go around
and I give presentations and,
and I tell people the concept is so
intuitive, you'll get it in 30 seconds.
Okay, so here it is fun the time
you're born until you're 18 years old.
You develop a personal moral code,
sense of right or wrong that could
come from your family, your religion,
community, friends, whatever.
And then you joined the military
and you learn a warrior code.
The Warrior Code is super imposed on
your personal moral code and in fact
transforms it somewhat.
Then you might have to participate in
activities or operations that violate your
personal moral code such as killing.
You don't have to be the
person that pulls the trigger.
You could be a witness or you could
feel that you should have prevented it.
Or You could be in a unit to follows
another unit and you see the innocent
civilians have been killed or you
handle body parts at that time.
You sustain a so called invisible
wounds of war called moral injury.
It's not a physical wound,
you can't see it.
But in military operations,
we're constantly moving.
You're going from point
a to point B to point c,
you don't have time to stop and reflect
on this stuff. So what do you do?
You Bury it and it
becomes unresolved grief,
shame.
And what happens is you come back to
the states and let's say you leave the
military or you're in the national
guard or reserves and you come back to a
community anywhere in the country that
doesn't understand what you've been
through.
And it boils up to the surface in,
unless you have a strong coping
mechanism for that, bad stuff happens.
Anger, guilt, depression, suicide.
And the suicide rate among veterans
today is epidemic. I mean the VA,
it's anywhere from 20 to 22 veterans
per day are dying by suicide and that
frankly is under reported.
It's really higher than that because
you've got veterans who are dying by
suicide is not reported as a suicide.
They'll drive their motorcycle or a
car into a tree or viaduct and it's a
vehicular accident.
Or unfortunately there's something called
suicide by cop where they forced the
law enforcement officer
to take lethal action.
And so what's,
what's the implication of all that?
We lose more veterans to suicide in a
year than all the combat does since nine
11.
That's how dramatic it was.
And we believe that moral injury is a
major contributing factor to that and
military outreach USA,
our organization,
we feel that the main approach to moral
injury is not a medical doctor with
prescription drugs.
It's the forgiveness and grace have a
moral authority and the counseling of
clergy and sensitive therapist and the
support of a community offering hope and
help. And so now getting back
that had an incident that,
that you asked me about Jocko, uh,
Allissa, you know, company commander,
Battle Company,
we'd just overrun a Vietcong position
and killed numerous enemy and I literally
had three dead bodies sent my feet.
Okay.
While the time a unit is most
vulnerable is right after a victory,
it's just human nature to let your
guard down and breathe a sigh of relief.
While I'm the guy in charge,
I know that.
So I'm on my radio and I'm
kicking rear end and taking names.
I'm telling my platoon leaders,
reorganize your units,
be distributed ammunition,
take care of your wounded,
look for enemy avenues of approach
for a counter attack. Right?
And in the middle of all that
stuff going on, I stopped
and I looked at the three
dead bodies at my feet.
I realized that something
had happened to me.
Something had hardened my heart.
Only moments earlier,
these were alive human beings.
They had families,
they had emotions,
they had loved ones,
they were fighting for something as
important to them as I was fighting for.
And I was in their backyard.
And then I remembered Jesus's sermon on
the mount where he told us to pray for
our enemies. So in the midst
of all this stuff going on,
I said a prayer for the three Vietcong.
And I know I was praying for myself
as much as I was praying for them.
Now you know, I didn't have a big
ceremony, get on my hands and knees,
any of that stuff, you know, this
is all took about 45 seconds.
But it's something that was seared in my
heart and mind for the rest of my life.
And now that I know about moral injury.
Okay. Which I didn't know at that time.
I realize that I was one in a million who
was able to address my moral injury at
the time that happened. Okay.
And you know, I'd always,
when I came back from Vietnam,
I had seen a lot of my
comrades having nightmares,
having flashbacks, you
know, personality changes.
And I frankly asked myself,
how come I'm not going through that?
Okay.
And at the time,
my answer always was my faith and my wife,
my wonderful wife of now
46 years who is an angel,
I've been so blessed having her for wife.
So that was my answer.
Okay.
But now since I've been
dealing with military outreach
USA and decision of moral
injury, I realized that my
answer was really lacking.
Okay.
There were two other things.
One was that incident in Vietnam
that I just mentioned to you.
But the other thing which I now realize
is when I came back from Vietnam,
I joined the reserves.
Okay.
And I was able to maintain my sense of
purpose of being in a unit with other
people who shared the same
values that I did of patriotism,
of dedication,
of selfless service,
which a lot of veterans when they
come back, they just want to cut ties.
Totally innate.
A lot of them drift because they
don't have that sense of purpose.
They don't have the camaraderie, they
don't have the bonding. You know,
I had that with the reservists and
especially, you know, in Viet, you know,
with Vietnam and all the bs that we
had to take from the public. You know,
I mean you won't believe this weight.
Well I know you know this,
but when we came back from Vietnam we
were told not to wear our uniforms in
public. I mean that's how
bad it was. Crazy. You know,
guys wore wigs so they,
people would know they had short haircuts,
you know, cause they could pick
them up. Is, is being military.
And so my being in the reserves helped me,
you know,
maintain that.
One of the things that I tell guys is
very similar to what you just said.
You know, I tell guys, you got to
find a new mission when you get done.
When you get done with the military,
you got to find a new mission.
And if you can stay in the reserves,
obviously that, that gives you that.
But if you don't do that well then you
got to find what are you going to do?
What are you going to step out there?
Are you going to become a great dad?
Are you going to build a business?
Are you going to work for a
company and do a great job?
Or you got to find a new mission. And I
f I find that guys that I've seen that,
that have real problems, it's because
they got out and they didn't know,
they didn't have any direction to go into.
And also what does the
dig a little bit deeper.
So you're in that situation
where you see these guys and,
and,
and for the first time you,
you kind of look down on them
and see them as people, as,
as other human beings. Is it, you know,
is it the fact that you,
when you,
when you said a prayer
for them and for yourself,
I kind of got an a thought of when you
hear about like native Americans hunting
and you know, they, they think, you
know, when, when they get a kill they'll,
they'll thank, you
know, Mother Nature and,
and thank for the sacrifice was at
that type of thing where you said,
okay, you know what, we're
fighting. I was doing my job.
You guys were doing your job
and I hope you have peace now.
It was,
it was at that type of thing.
Absolutely. Because you
know, what happens is
you forget that they're,
they're dehumanized, right?
You know, you've got all these,
all these names that you call them,
you know,
but I've really respected the VC,
our enemy,
you know, and that's, uh,
that's the other thing.
You can't underestimate your enemy.
You always have to respect them.
You have, you know, I mean,
you don't have to agree
with them, but you, you,
you have to respect their abilities.
Because once you lose track of that,
you can really get screwed.
And basically, uh, I'll,
I'll give you some examples.
When we had that battle on 22 may,
okay, I was in the CNC helicopter with,
and I guess I should describe that battle
a little bit more. Cigarette listeners.
We're, we're talking about, uh,
the hardcore battalion and when
we surround this, this, this VC,
uh, training battalion, you really
is what it was and we annihilated it.
Basically they were,
they in circled and we were
just calling in air strikes,
naval gunfire,
you know,
we were just taking then Hackworth
had them totally in circle.
And so I'll never forget, I was in the
helicopter with him and he basically said,
move. Uh, we got, uh,
first we get a radio message from one
of our companies who might've been alert
company and they said, we just had a
contact, you know, we killed three,
we've can't, you know,
we got four weapons,
we captured a guy or whatever and
they're headed in this direction. Okay.
So hackers with turned to me and
say, look, you know, let's say,
give him 15 minutes,
we're going to hear from battle company.
15 minutes later, battle company comes
up, we just had her contact, you know,
and they were headed. And so this
happened all day. Okay, I saw this,
I was with them then the helicopter and,
but there was one VC,
we were flying near a canal
and he was mortally wounded.
You could see the guy was dying,
basically.
He took his Ak 47 and he
threw it into the canal.
Okay.
And the reason he did that is he didn't
want us to get that weapon because part
of the body count,
uh,
was you matched how many weapons you,
you know what I mean?
If a unit B port and they said, well,
we killed 20 and we got one weapon,
you kind of say, wait a second. You know,
so when I saw that I knew that this guy,
you know,
we were up against a tough
enemy, you know, and and uh,
so,
so you got to respect your enemy and
I want to pull some,
before we move past a Vietnam and hack,
I want to pull some stuff out of about
face just to kind of hear you hear your,
your thoughts on it.
I'm going to start off with one that
you've talked about a little bit,
but here we go.
This is from about face by David Hackworth
and this is a quote from someone else
says hack had the knack of being
able to size people up very quickly,
almost instantaneously.
And I'd say 99% of the time he was right.
He could look at a person and in his
vernacular the guy was either a stud or he
wasn't,
there was no in between.
If he was a stud hack would
find a way to get him.
And he would not take no from people
if you wanted them because he wanted a
winning team. And if a person
didn't want to go with him,
then immediately the guy wasn't a stud,
you see,
because anybody who knew hack or came
into contact with him really wanted to be
with him after he'd known him for a while.
And that's a quote from Brigadier
General James H Uchiyama,
which is you,
you're quoted in the book
and you've talked about that
a little bit and he just,
he must have had extremely
magnetic personality for you to say
that if you spent time with him,
you wanted to be with him.
Oh, absolutely. And, and he,
I used to say he had the midas touch.
Everything that guy touched,
just whether it was in the military,
whether it was in business,
whether it was with women.
I mean, this guy, you know,
he was a stud of himself and, uh,
and, you know, and, but he was,
he was also a sensitive guy.
I'll never forget when, uh,
you know, I tell people he wasn't
the most moral guy that I knew. Uh,
but he was the,
the most ethical officer
I ever served with.
What I mean by that is he never
did anything for personal gain.
Uh, he always did things for the
unit and for the soldiers. Okay.
But did he have affairs and things like
that? Yeah, and he used to tell me,
he said, Moocs, you know,
I should've never married
because my love is the army,
you know, so he, he basically,
he turned down the war college.
He could have gone to the workout. He
turned it down because he said, hey,
I'm on another battalion in
Vietnam. You know, I mean,
he would have been a journal.
There's no question about it. Uh,
had had he not stood off, you know,
when he was no. Six and, and uh,
and you know, he, I think he was the
youngest oh six at that time in the army.
But he was a guy who, who was, uh,
he was sensitive though, and he took care.
He did take care of his family effect.
I can say this now because it's,
you know,
I think statute of limitations
might be gone, but you know,
in those days you weren't,
you were enabled to take a
lot of cash out of Vietnam,
you know, and uh, and I basically,
one day he knew I was going
back home. Oh. And by the way,
he did everything he could to convince
me to stay to extend in Vietnam.
Okay. He was, he had moved down to be the,
the senior advisor for the
Arvin airborne division,
which is really the palace
guard around Saigon. Okay.
And he knew all my hot buttons.
You have to understand,
I was a bachelor guy at this
time, right. And, and uh,
and the Arab board, the Vietnamese
airborne war, a special fatigues.
They were like tiger fatigue and
they had red berets, you know,
and I'm just this young stud guy who
likes uniforms. And he said, look,
he said,
why don't you come down here and
I'll make you the g one advisor.
That's the Admin Guy, right? And
he said, but when you come down,
if you're an advisor for the Vietnamese
airborne, you get jumped, pay, you don't.
So that's extra money.
Right. And, and he said,
and I'll give you two are in ours.
Cause he knew I wanted to go to Japan
and see my relatives. So six months,
he started giving you a two hour
now. Right. So the guys, you know,
he's trying to move the, you
know, the sun and the moon.
They get me new extent six months
then. And I said, sir, I appreciate it,
but I had some close calls and I figured
the next one would have muckle yama
written. Yeah. Bullet, what happened? Walk
me home a written none. And I said, uh,
no thanks. I appreciate it,
but I'm, I'm Outta here. So,
so I left,
you know,
you're talking about the way he was,
so,
so pro army and yet he rebelled
against the army in away and here,
here's a,
another thing from the book.
Okay.
He says,
what a mistake it was to listen to the
generals of corporate HQ who were briefed
only in zero defect terms.
And so far from the cutting
edge expected nothing less.
It was amongst the biggest
mistakes of the war.
The politicians only listened to these
generals and the generals only listened
to themselves.
Few people asked frontline soldiers,
the only ones who really knew.
Could you guys or could you,
cause you were pretty close to him.
Could you sense that his
frustration with the army,
did he talk about it with you? Did
he, how did he treat, you know,
that's a very hard thing for
a, for a leader to do. If your,
if your senior leadership is telling you
to do stuff that doesn't make sense or,
but you know, hey, we can get it
done and we're going to do it.
It's a hard line to walk to say,
look, we support the chain of command.
This is what they're telling us to do.
I'm going to spin it in a positive way.
Everyone's going to think that we're
doing it for the right reasons.
Because if I say, hey look Merk,
here's what I want you to do and it's,
it's dumb but we're getting told to do it
anyways. That's not a good way to lead.
No. So he wouldn't say that. So he would,
he would support the chain and, yeah,
and he, he would, he
would present it in a,
in a way in which,
you know,
would talk about the nation and he would
make sure that he would accomplish the
mission, but he would
do it his way, you know,
and you know the phrase battlefield
expediency, that's so we did all the time,
you know, I mean, screw it. What,
you know, what are they going to do?
Send us to Vietnam. We were already
there, you know, so, you know,
we just did what we had to
do and you know, I mean,
the stupid rules of engagement
that we had, you know,
where you'd have to get approval to fire
on people even though you're receiving
fire, you know, and, and just nutty
stuff. Right. You know, and we just say,
hey, you know, we're going to do what
we have to do. And that's what we did.
[inaudible].
Here's when he, uh, when he took
over the battalion the following day,
I took over the battalion from
Lieutenant Colonel Franklin,
a heart in a parade field exchange of,
in the middle of the Mekong Delta.
What kind of war have I gotten
myself into? I wondered,
a perfectly starch
General Ewell was there,
having flown in for the occasion
in his polished choppers.
There was other brass too, and
photographers, the American flag,
the battalion colors,
which were ceremoniously passed on to
me and all of this before the scrounge,
easiest, most spiritless assembly
of soldiers I'd ever seen.
Incredibly,
none of the generals or Kernels seem
to notice the slack condition of my new
charges or their positions.
From the outset,
I realized that to make this unit
effective military force that have to
implement about a thousand changes,
so I figured we'd start with five a day.
Little things,
basic things like where your steel pot
and cleaned and carry your rifle at all
times and ammunition will not be worn.
Poncho via style.
My for first order was that
darkness that come darkness.
The fire support base perimeter
would pull back 300 meters.
The troops instantly began
to grumble about this,
but it was the next order that really
began the muteness feeling within my hard
luck outfit. Anything you can't carry 24
hours a day is gone in the next chopper,
chopper,
good buy tents and cots and rucksacks and
food Docker's the bitching and moaning
begin in earnest as piles and piles of
junk mounted at the Lz to be whisked away
by Chinuch.
But I didn't care.
I wasn't there to have them like me.
Again, we, we already
talked about this and I,
this comes up a lot from a
leadership perspective. Do you,
is it more important to be liked or
is it more important to be respected?
Is it more important to,
and I actually had a guy asked
me this question the other day,
is it more important
to win or to be liked?
And I said, well, those two things
aren't mutually exclusive at all. Right?
You're absolutely correct.
And they're not mutually exclusive.
You know,
if you demonstrate to your soldiers
that you care for them professionally,
that's you'll be liked.
There's no question because they know
that you're there for them and you know,
you don't, as as it said there, you know,
you're not there to win a
popularity contest. You know,
you're not there to be
politically correct.
You're there to accomplish your mission,
but also make sure that
your guys come back.
And I think I'm, I'm
starting to tie together, um,
but something very clearly in my head
right now. And that is, you know, your,
your number two rule of leadership,
which is caring.
And I think if you,
if you care about your people and
they see that you care about them,
that trumps the fact that you want
them to do things the right way.
Because the reason you want him to do the
things the right way is cause you care
about them and it's going to keep
them alive. They make you successful.
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely. Uh, you know, I,
when I was a young officer,
I,
okay,
well no, I, at that time when I was a
company, can we, after Hackworth left,
we had another battalion
commander come in, right?
And he wrote on my OER all my career,
I had Max OERs, really good stuff. But um,
and this one,
he wrote that and I'll take
this hit any day of the week.
He said I was too concerned
or my troops sometimes.
Wow. And uh, and I said,
okay, I'll take that.
Wow. That's interesting perspective. Yeah.
And you know,
this is one of those dichotomies as well.
Okay.
Because one of the hardest things about
being a leader is obviously you care
about your men so much and yet
you are going to do things.
You are going to put them in situations
that they're going to put their lives at
risks at risk.
And that is,
that is something that every leader has
to release military leaders to have to,
okay.
They have to find a way to get a handle
on that because you love your guys and
you want to take care of them, but you do
have to do your mission. Yep. And that,
that's one of the hardest
things to balance.
Talking about the morality of war a
little bit. This was a, and again,
this is why you know that the
story that I opened up with,
you could see that that one
clearly had to do with with,
okay,
having moral dilemmas and having guilt
because Hackworth gave a guy in order and
the guy followed the order.
Maybe not the way Hackworth 40 was,
but the moral injury that he got from
that he said lasted his whole life of
giving an order and somebody
does something and you
didn't expect to do them.
They end up getting killed.
It's one of his guys when his guys that
he loved gets killed because of the way
he led.
Here's another kind of moral situation.
Going back to the book.
They're flying around. They're on a
mission. We went down to about 100 feet.
The suspects were still running,
but this closer inspection
confirmed my initial feeling.
They were just eight kids,
no older than 13 or 14 simply
scared shitless as they ran.
Looking for cover, caring, neither
weapons nor military equipment.
No, I told the pilot, I don't
give you permission to fire.
I'll put an infantry insert on them.
I instructed the platoon leader whose
men were aboard the four slicks.
Where to land.
Yeah.
With gun ships covering the platoon,
hit the ground.
The immediately received small arms
fire and took a couple of wounded.
Okay.
The little kids were, as my savvy pilot
had said from the outset, Vietcong,
yeah.
It was a major learned for me,
but one impossible to etch in stone.
I had a couple of men wounded who would
not have been if I just said to blow
those kids away,
but I couldn't say blow him away
because they appeared on armed. Yes,
they were VC,
but they could just as well have been
kids ditching school who happened to get
caught in the crossfire.
Anything was possible and I suddenly
realized it would not be easy.
This delta war,
it wasn't easy to tell the good guys from
the bad guys anywhere in South Vietnam,
but here in the delta it
was damn near impossible.
Okay.
Again,
very similar to what my guys dealt with
over in Ramadi was very hard to tell who
was good and who was bad and the
enemy knew they could just put the,
drop the weapon and walk away.
And now they were considered innocent
even though 20 seconds prior to that they
were shooting.
How did you keep your men from becoming
so callous that they were just going to
start shooting kids because
they suspected they were VC?
How hard did you have
to keep control of that?
Well,
I,
my response to that is the American
soldier innately is ethical.
It's, it's in our culture not
to shoot women and children.
Now guys, you know, if
there were, you know,
that that might be
something else, but, uh, we,
and we do not
shoot civilians. Just, you
know, who are, who are,
are, uh, were caught with, you know, we,
we run across them just because they're
there and we want to take revenge.
We don't do that as an army.
Yeah. Generally speaking.
Now there are times when people lose it.
And I understand that that's,
that's the stress of war and
it's happened in all wars.
I don't condone it, but
I can understand. Uh,
and so to answer your question,
we really didn't have to our guys who
are pretty professional and I was proud,
proud to serve with them. I didn't,
they didn't, I didn't see any of that.
Okay.
Yeah. And this, this just tells me,
once again it's about leadership.
I mean cause here you can see hack
clearly leaning towards making sure he's
doing the right thing,
even though he's a guy that loves his
troops and wants to take care of him,
he's still leans towards doing the right
thing. And from what you're saying,
that filtered all the way through
the chain of command. And we,
we took an in depth look,
I've actually done two podcasts
concerning the mee Lai massacre and what
happened there.
And it was just so clear
that the leadership was
completely fault and the way
that they lead those troops,
and it was when I went through to try
and pull something positive out of the
meal,
I massacre the positive message that
I got from it was that it was one,
it was one officer who had flown, he
was Thompson, I believe his name was,
but he'd flown over, he'd seen what
was happening. He flew back to base,
told the senior leadership,
this is what's going on in the ground.
The senior leadership radioed into the
field and say, stop killing people.
And the,
they literally instantly stopped.
They stopped the masker just because
a leader stepped up and said, stop.
So good leadership completely changed
the situation as it was ongoing.
And,
and clearly,
if there would've been a better leader
on the ground that was leading in the
right way,
it never would have even started.
So you can see here
from what hacks saying,
the way he led and the way
he treated unknown, you know,
people. And then the way that was
carried out through the whole battalion.
That's another amazing
testament to good leadership.
Yeah. And, and one thing about me lie,
which I tell people is that it was the
exception approved the rule that United
States military, that that was
an exception. Oh yeah. Yup.
You know, the, the rule in our
military is we don't, we don't do that.
And that proved it. I mean,
I, I didn't see, you know,
there were other armies there
who were more ruthless, like the,
like the Rock, the rocks were
not there. The Republic of Korea,
they were not there. The win, the
hearts and minds of the people,
they were there to win the war.
So if they would go buy a
village and they were fired upon,
they'd destroy the village.
And after a while,
nobody fired on the rocks.
When Hackworth now gets,
well,
he got wounded in eighth time.
Yeah. I thought you were getting to
that when you read that one quote.
But the way now,
I wasn't there with him when he,
when he got his eighth purple
heart. Uh, but I know the story and,
and basically there were guys who were in,
in bad shape and he lands
his CNC in the middle of the,
in fact that might have been
there and maybe you didn't,
they landed it in the middle
of a firefight or hacked did.
He ordered the pilot that take them down
and he does put the wound to guys into
the CNC. Well the CNC isn't that big.
You know, there's no room for Hec.
So he stands on the skits and they
take off and he gets it in the lake.
And that was his, a purple
heart. Well after that, you know,
he could tell the guys in the battalion,
I want you to walk through this wall
of fire. And the response would be,
where do you want us to go? You
know, he, he led by example.
Is that what caused the army? You say,
okay, we're gonna did they pull it?
Did they pull them from the battalion
at that point when he got his eighth
portfolio? Pretty much that was,
that was it. Cause what was,
if you got three purple hearts, you
went home. Was that, was that the deal?
I only had one,
but I have no idea.
They basically said, you know, we
can't afford to lose you and if they,
you know,
if you get killed,
I mean that's a vague kit and
just the morale and you know,
and so you're Outta, you're
outta there in the field. Okay.
So he went up to play
coup to become the deputy.
He was the GC three core
advisor for two core. Okay.
Which was the central highlands.
And when my company was pulled out of
Vietnam, be few Sicko, I said, hey,
I want to stay here. I called half
and I said, sir, you know, I don't,
I don't really want to go back.
Can you use me?
I had orders the next day to go to flake.
Who,
and then you went up to
play. Cool. And you start,
you guys were doing advising for
the Marvin? Yes, we, we were the,
we were the Mac v that's a
military assistance command,
Vietnam people. And, uh, I had, uh,
there was a close call that I had when,
uh,
this was another moral
injury thing by the way,
which I really had really buried,
had not really thought a lot about it,
but we,
we had an inspection team that went
out on the special forces camps on the
border of Cambodia and Laos and Vietnam.
And you had pleasuring,
Ben had docto, uh, in
the central highlands.
And so we would fly into
these camps. And, uh,
there were three people on this
inspection team, so to speak.
It was the deputy corps advisor who
was an o six, a full colonel, you know,
big deal. There was the command sergeant,
major, highest ranking enlisted,
uh, advisor, also a big deal. And
I was the young captain, okay.
Carrying everything, but he's
bags and note takers, right? So,
so we land on this special forces,
this camp,
and we come under attack and
the sergeant major is killed.
And he was maybe 20 meters away from
me and was a rocket. And it was just,
he was in the wrong place. You know, it
could have been me if I was, you know,
if had to come in the other direction.
Well,
the backside of that story is that he was
scheduled to go on rnr the next day to
Hawaii to meet his waiting wife to
celebrate their 25th wedding anniversary.
Okay.
Now I wish I was just a young captain,
but I outranked him. Okay. I could
have ordered him not to go on
that mission. Why risk
it, you know, cause he,
he was going to meet his wife the
next day. I didn't do that. Okay.
And I,
I've thought about that in terms of
survivor guilt and in all of that,
uh, it was, uh, uh, and that's
something that's come up in my,
you know,
my studying this moral injury stuff
at this point. Did you, you're,
so now you're working with Hackworth
directly and are you starting to sense his
frustration about the war at all?
Yeah, a little bit. Uh, yet, well, no,
more than a little bit because the,
the,
the
g three for the core was a fairly corrupt,
a guy and a Hackworth was
very frustrated with that.
And, uh, that's why he left actually. Uh,
well let's backtrack. I, I, uh, yeah, he,
he was moved down to
the Vietnamese airborne
cause he really was not happy.
I think he might've been moved.
I never really got the story on that,
why he went down there.
And now at this point,
what's your,
what are you thinking about
your career in your life?
I'd already decided I was
resigning when I got back
to the states. And what made you,
what made you lean in that direction?
Because I mean,
you did more years in JRTC than
anyone has ever done before.
And did,
you,
did ROTC and you had all that military
stuff and now you've got your combat tour
in Vietnam. Under what, what, what
tilted you and the other direction?
Uh, I felt the army was going in
the wrong direction when it came to
leadership.
I thought that they were looking
for managers and not commanders.
Uh,
I was in some positions during my career.
I had access to,
uh,
officer efficiency reports and I could
see where the ratings of the senior
officers, that lieutenant colonels
and the battalion commanders were.
The tendency was to give the
managers high ratings, uh, Irri
irrespective of their
command and abilities.
And then my personal career was,
was not managed very well.
Uh, Hackworth, Hackworth wanted
me to stay. He knew I was,
I was thinking of resigning and the neck.
That's why he offered me the company,
cause you know, he thought that experience
might turn things around, you know.
And so I'm here I am at still with
Hackworth in the battalion. Right.
And he contacted his friends at
the, and he said, listen you guys,
we got a stud here and he's
thinking of leaving, you know,
show him some personal attention. We
got a chance to save him. You know,
he told me this later. So I get this
letter from the Pentagon, you know what,
I'm out in the middle of nowhere,
you know,
and I first letter they had ever sent me
and they said, dear captain McCall, yum.
We have reviewed your two
oh one file very carefully.
Right.
And we believe you have
promised for graduate school.
Okay.
Only problem is I already had my masters,
which means that they didn't really pay
a lot of tension right there would be
view. I, I showed the letter to hack and I
said, hey, you know, I mean this is crazy.
Yo, I'm going to put my career in
the hands of these guys, you know?
And that pretty well sealed it for me.
And so did you,
did you submit your resignation while you
were still in Vietnam or to come home?
As soon as I came home I did. I wanted to
finish the tour in Vietnam, which I did.
And then I told the army, um,
I'm going to be Outta here,
you know? And so they assigned me
to Fort Sheridan, Illinois. Right.
Cause I lived in Chicago and I finished,
I have three months there
and then I was done.
And then did you,
at what point did you decide
you were gonna stay in the
reserves? Oh, immediately.
That was never a question
I was committed to doing.
20 years turned out to
be 32, but I, you know,
I was committed to doing 20 because
especially at that time in 70,
71,
the reserve components didn't have
a lot of combat experienced guys.
And I felt that it was
important that I try to help,
you know, the reserves
be ready basically. Uh,
and I had something to contribute.
So that's why I joined the reserves.
And then you start on your
civilian career. Yeah. Yeah.
And what happened there was I,
I worked for a Japanese importing
and exporting company. Uh,
it's called a trading company and it
was a name of the company was Mitsui and
it's world.
We know we used to have a saying that
the sun never set on Mitsui because they
had offices in like 165 countries.
Okay.
And it was a very prestigious company.
If anybody,
they had quote unquote Mitsui men,
you know, if you were a Mitsui Guy,
that was a big deal. It was like their
Harvard graduates would all go there,
you know,
and things like that.
And I was at the Chicago
office and the problem was,
I actually experienced reverse
discrimination by that when,
I mean is that I had
studied Japanese history,
political science and Japanese language
a little bit at the University of
Illinois. Okay. And I had
a pretty good work ethic.
Okay. And, but they couldn't,
it couldn't compute in their mind that
I'm talking about the Japanese. Okay.
All,
all the manager positions where Japanese,
like the branch manager, he was a vice
president, you know, and all that.
I had no opportunity to ever get to
even to be a department manager in that
company because they looked at me
and they couldn't compute that.
I didn't speak Japanese fluently.
Okay. So was in their mind,
I'm the village idiot. You know, even
though I have my master's degree,
I had commanded a company in combat.
I had signed for $10
million worth of equipment,
I had more responsibility in life and
these guys will ever know, you know,
but they didn't get it.
They don't understand that.
So I did that for about five
years. I mean, I was treated well.
I have no complaints. But you know, I,
and I didn't expect any guarantees,
but I had hoped I would have
an opportunity to compete.
And when I saw that wasn't the,
that wasn't going to happen. Uh,
I had a roommate,
a from the U of I who was a member of
the Chicago board options exchange and
options trading was just
starting at that time. And He,
he was, uh, a great visionary,
a little weak on details.
And so he had an operation on the floor
of the exchange and he realized he
needed to get a handle on that.
And I'm pretty good with details.
So he called me and he said,
Jim, I know you're not happy.
You know where you're at, which
you want to come work with me. And,
and I said, hey, wait a second. You
know, I don't have one day of finance,
formal education. I didn't know the
difference between a stock and a bond or,
you know, must less a stock option.
And he said, don't worry about it.
I know your abilities, you're
good with math. You know,
this is not rocket scientist stuff.
And I said, okay, I'll do it.
And that started out a 35 year career
in financial services industry and I
became a member of the
New York Stock Exchange,
the Chicago board options exchange.
I was very blessed.
I became part owner of the company.
So that enabled me to devote all the time
I did into reserves that I did because
that was part of the deal I made
with my friend. I said, listen,
if you want me to join you,
I'm bringing the reserves with me
and you have to understand, you know,
if I'm called,
I'm going and if I'm in the
reserves I'm going to give it 100%,
you know, and, and, but he
was, he had gone through our
TC with me. Okay. So he was,
he was an army officer,
so he understood.
So I was able to have a successful career.
At the same time.
You moved up really
quickly through the ranks in the reserves.
Yeah, I had, I had a life,
like I said before, Jocko,
I had great NC hosts who made me look
good. I had commanders who mentored me.
Uh,
I was,
I was a brigadier general at the age of
42 and I was a major general three years
later, obviously the youngest general
in the army at the time. Uh, so yeah,
I was,
I was challenged,
I had great assignments and so, uh, I,
I was very blessed and my wife supported
me through all of this. Without her,
I would not have been able
to get the first face.
I noticed you, you mentioned a couple
times a General William Levine yes.
And,
and sort of the impact that he had on you,
he was a guy that landed a DDA at Utah
beach and was one of the people that
liberate a dark hour and in World War II.
Yes.
Was there any significant lesson learned
that he passed on to you that yeah,
absolutely. He, he,
I think he's personally
responsible for that balance.
Part of my leadership concept that
I've developed over my career,
uh, he really emphasize
family and, and keep in mind,
when I joined the reserves, I didn't
have a clue about the citizen soldier,
you know,
those of us on active duty.
What do we know about the garden
reserves and their pressure,
you know what they deal with,
you know,
people in the garden reserves have to
balance three balls at the same time.
Right? You've got your, your family,
you've got your civilian career,
the puts bread and butter on the table,
and then you've got the reserve.
So the guard, you know, which, you know,
and so you're balancing while
that stuff and General Levine,
I'll always remember,
emphasize the family.
He always made sure that we were aware of,
uh, the stresses on the family. You know,
when we were gone, I'll never
forget her, my career without fail.
That's when the furnace would break down.
That's when we'd have a blizzard.
So my 95 pound wife would have to go
out there and shovel the snow cause I
wasn't there. You know, our son
Jay, who's who, who, you know, uh,
he,
he basically was a rascal when he was
the young guy and my wife had to take him
to the emergency room in the
hospital like three times.
I don't even know where
it's at times a week.
And I don't even know where it's at. You
know, cause I wasn't home. So, you know,
distresses out enough.
So he really drove that
home and I understood better
the stresses on the citizen
soldier, which are tremendous. You know,
at least when you're on active duty,
you're focused,
you know,
and you're in a community where everybody
has gone through the same thing.
So they all understand, you know, the
stresses on the marriage. They, you know,
they share things, they can help each
other out. But in new reserves, in guard,
you know, the rest of the, you go
to a meeting one weekend a month,
you know, and unless you're in leadership,
you know, that's about it. And,
uh, you know, you don't have the,
you don't have the bonding
and the community a strength
that you do when you're
on active duty.
Yeah.
When we got to Ramadi,
it was the two to eight National Guard
unit out of Pennsylvania and reserve
units that were on the ground
and they'd been there for,
I think they'd been there for 14 months,
but boy,
they were outstanding soldiers. All
of them. There was a real honor to,
to work with them a little bit and then
get the turnover and great guys, they,
you rent,
you ended up running training for like
21 out of your 25 years in the reserves.
That's, that's, that's a
lot of training to run.
Yeah. I was, once again, I'd say,
now you've heard me say this before,
it's a god thing. Uh, basically, uh,
the army was the only service
that really had a great,
uh,
process where we had reserve units
whose wartime mission was the takeover,
the training centers,
you know,
like the Great Lakes naval
training center, you know,
but the Navy didn't have that.
The air force didn't have that.
The Marines didn't have that.
We had reserve units that their war time
mission was to go to Fort Benning for
example.
That was my division's mission was to
go to Fort Benning and take over the
training of the infantry
officers and recruits,
not officers to recruits at Fort Benning.
So that the active duty soldiers
that were already there,
who are up to speed on everything,
you know,
could go join fighting units basically.
So that was, that was the mission.
All right. So I joined when
I came off of active duty,
I joined the 85th training division in
Chicago and that was an infantry training
division at the time and I was with
them for 18 years and I commanded co,
uh, at the company level,
battalion co level,
Brigade Level and LSE
assistant division commander.
And every year we've,
uh,
gone annual training to a active duty
training for it and we take over the
training of the recruits. So I did
it at Dick's, I did it at Fort Bliss.
I did it at Ford Ord.
And then finally with the 70th,
I did it at Fort Benning. And so, uh,
then what happened was I,
I was the commander of the 70th division,
uh,
out of Livonia, Michigan
and Desert Storm came. Okay.
And I knew we were going to
be mobilized, uh, you know,
the handwriting was on the wall.
Okay.
So I put together a list of,
I had 16 subordinate units in my,
I have three brigades in the
training command and other things.
And so I made a list of ones to 16,
and I prioritize them. Okay. And I,
and it was a mixture of
readiness and leadership,
you know, that's how I prioritize them.
Then I also had to be sensitive to, uh,
I had units in Indiana and Michigan,
so I couldn't take all the Michigan
units and Liebau Indiana guys.
That wouldn't have been fair because
everybody wanted it to be mobilized.
Okay. You have to understand
this was, this is when,
this would be the first time.
Okay.
And we've been practicing
for like 25 years, you know,
you're ready for Game Day. Yeah. So
the question is if the balloon went up,
what people show up, you know, and so, so
I had this list and I went to trade doc,
which was our, uh, a higher
headquarters at Fort Monroe, Virginia.
And I said, listen, here's my
list. Here's my division. Okay?
I said,
use this list and if you're going to
mobilize my division or any part of my
division,
do it in disorder and
don't screw with this.
This is the best way. This is the
best way my division will serve,
you know, the army, did
they comply? Oh yeah,
they were delighted is ask them.
I wasn't the only division
commander that had done that.
So they went out to the other 11
division commanders and they, hey,
say we need some lists,
you know, and that,
and they did exactly what I told them
to do because they mobilized half of my
division. So they just went right down
the list, you know, down to eight or nine.
And then that was it.
And now you ended up having kind of
a run in at the end of your career?
Yeah, I had several. I, you know,
and it was because of Hackworth,
you know, about face and,
and uh, and the first one was, uh,
I went on the Oprah Winfrey
show and, uh, basically,
uh, um, my mom was still
alive at that time.
She used to watch Oprah during the day
and Oprah was out of Chicago. Right.
And then she, and she used to it. I
didn't know this cause I never watched it,
but she used to announce ahead of time,
uh,
subjects that she was going to cover.
And if anybody knew anyone who were
experts in that area of let her know,
you know, so she could get them. So she
decided this is in the late eighties.
Okay.
Now put yourself back at that time when
the economy was not doing so hot and the
Japanese economy was doing real good,
you know, because of their computers,
their automobile stir televisions.
And so people were blaming the Japanese
about our poor economic situation.
And uh,
it was called Japan bashing.
So in fact there was a Chinese guy's
name was victor Chen who was killed in
Detroit by some automobile workers with
baseball bats because they thought he
was Japanese. He was
actually Chinese. Okay.
So over decided to have a show
about Japan bashing. So she said,
if anybody knows anyone,
you know,
and the Japanese American community
to where it might be a good, you know,
person on this, please let me know.
Well, my mom saw that and she said,
you need to get on the show,
you know?
So I tried calling, I couldn't get,
you know how this is, you know,
I couldn't get through whatever.
Why have a very, I had at that time,
a very influential journalists in Chicago.
His name was earth cups in it,
who had a very famous,
it's called cups column.
He used to interview presidents,
kings and Queens, political
people, you know, at,
in Chicago,
at a restaurant.
And so I called cup and I
said, hey, because you know,
I'm trying to get through on this
thing with Oprah. And, and he said,
I'll see what I can do.
Okay.
Two hours later I get a call from the
executive producer of the show and he
says, I understand that you're a
general in the army. I said, yeah,
I'm in the army reserves and,
and that you're the highest ranking Asian
American and our armed forces today.
And I said, yeah, that's right.
And he said, well, and, and I,
I was trying to figure out where
the guy was going. Right. Well,
he was trying to see if I could
chew gum and walk at the same time.
So once he figured I could
do that, he said, you know,
we'd like to have you on the show. Okay.
So I said, fine, when is it? Tomorrow.
Okay. So I said, okay,
I'm in. So I called my,
at that time I was working for in New
York Stock Exchange firm and I called the
headquarters in New York. I said, hey, I
need a day off. So they gave it to me. Uh,
and then I called the chief of army
reserves office. Cause keep in mind,
I'm a two star general, right. And I
said, Hey, I'm going on the Oprah show,
you know, and uh, what's the subject
while the subject is Japan bashing,
but I'm being invited because,
you know,
I'm high ranking Japanese American in our
army and I'm going to wear my uniform,
you know, so, uh, I get a call back. Okay.
From the chief of public affairs of
the army. Now he's a one star. No.
Okay. Okay. And I'm a two star.
Okay. So he calls and he said,
I'm understanding you're going to be
on the Oprah show. Yeah, that's right.
What's the subject? Japan bashing.
Oh, it's not about the army. No,
it's not about the military at all.
You know,
but I'm being invited because I'm the
highest ranking Japanese American in the
army, in the military. You, the whole
military and being an o eight at the time.
And he said, well then we don't
want you to wear your uniform. Okay.
And I said,
listen,
I take my responsibility very seriously
as a role model from minorities.
This is a great opportunity to let people
know that we have equal opportunity in
our armed forces. I don't
see this as a, as a, uh,
as a possibility to fail.
I see this is a opportunity to succeed.
And I,
and I just said, I, you know,
I don't really have a lot of time for
this because it was going to be the next
day, right. So I said, is
this an order, you know,
from, you know, the secretary or from
the chief, I don't care. You know,
whoever's above me, is
this an order? And he said,
why can't tell you it's in order?
And I said, well, okay, in that case,
thank you very much for calling me.
You know,
I appreciate what you said.
I've taken it all in under consideration.
Bottom line, I'm wearing my uniform.
And that was the end of it. Okay.
So he writes a memorandum for record that
to the chief of staff in the army that
went into my file that said, you know,
I spoke to general and woke me Alma.
I told him it was,
you know,
above his pay grade levels that you
might get involved with, you know,
things that went out of hand and all that.
And he basically told me that he
was going to wear his uniform. So,
so I go on to show, okay, and
I'm ready. I do my homework.
Okay.
And we've come back from commercial
break and Oprah starts out by saying,
and today we have with us
Major General Jim [inaudible],
the highest ranking Asian American,
Japanese American in our
military today camera.
And I'm going to sit there
and the civilian suit, I mean,
what kind of a message would that been?
I was in my class, ace, of course. Okay.
And the first words out
of my mouth were Oprah.
I want everyone to understand that
whatever I say today is the opinion of Jim
McWilliam.
I am not representing the Department
of the army of not representing the
Department of Defense. However, I am
a soldier in the United States army.
I'm proud of it.
We have equal opportunity in our armed
forces and the message and the rest of
the thing went very well.
And they actually had a guy on there who
I would affectionately referred to as a
redneck, and he was blaming the
Japanese for all the problems of,
and some of it was correct where
they weren't fair in, in, uh,
some of the economic dealings
with us. Uh, you know, they were,
their markets were not as open to our
products is they should have been. Uh,
but on the other hand, the guy was seeing
some nutty stuff. Like he said, well,
they're costing US jobs.
Okay. So I said, okay,
who's the fourth largest automobile
manufacturer in the country?
The answer Honda America.
Okay.
They have a plant in Marysville,
Ohio that employed 3,500 American gay.
They can't close that plan
and take advantage your pan.
It's in the United States.
And I said,
I'm also tired of hearing people complain
about an American quality because the
Honda civics produced at that plant have
fewer defects than Honda civics that
were coming from Japan. Jd powers.
I had, I had all this stuff
with the general. So then I told
them, I said, and guess what?
The steel for that plant
comes from Indiana,
which is also jobs for Americans.
Okay.
Then the other thing the guy said was the,
the uh,
the Asians are taking over
our universities. I said,
what's that all about?
And he said, well, they're getting all the
scholarships. Okay. And I said, listen,
the Asian Americans are not smarter
than any other ethnicity or race.
The reason they do so well in school is
the parents get involved and they make
sure that their kids study and they
emphasize the value of education.
That got a huge approval
from the audience. You know?
So what happened was there was a,
believe it or not,
a federal judge in Chicago
who saw that program. Okay.
So he writes a letter to the
secretary of defense saying you don't,
unless I saw it,
the Oprah show and there was this
major general Jim Mccoy Yam who,
who really did a great job for you guys
and you guys should be proud of him.
Right. So the secretary of defense
at that time was Dick Cheney.
Okay. So he endorses the letter
down to the secretary of the army.
The secretary of the army endorses the
letter down to the chief of staff of the
army. So when that hits
my file, same time,
the other thing hit my file,
basically one canceled the
other photo copy of that back.
But that's, you know,
so right then and there,
the army knew what they were dealing
with. Cause I, you know, I've always,
you know,
it was an opportunity to show that we
have equal opportunity armed forces.
I tell people that one of the proudest
things of my service was that when I
would lose track of people's,
you know,
I stopped looking at people as,
as Asian American or African
American or Hispanic Americans.
I looked at them as private corporal,
Lieutenant,
whatever their job was,
uh, in the military.
That's how I caught myself forgetting
sometimes of people, you know,
cause I tell people everybody
was all of dram. Yeah. Yeah.
So that was my first,
uh,
no, you started to say
that the book, the book,
did the book start to play any
kind of role in your career?
Did people start talking to
you about Hackworth Book?
Uh, no, not really. That,
that'd be when I mean by that is,
you know,
the whole stance that he
took about Vietnam to risk
his career and just actually
just saying, Hey, I'm outta
here cause you know, I've,
I've done this now for 30 something
years and frankly it was weighing on him.
I mean,
talk about the moral injury of knowing
that you're leading soldiers in combat
when
they could have been,
the policy could have been done better,
which would have resulted
in fewer casualties.
Yeah, that's, that's, I dunno if there's
a heavier weight to bear than that,
that to everyone. And then what was
the next thing you took a stance on?
Well,
the next thing that happened,
which caused the end of my
career basically is, uh,
I liked that you say that
with a smile on your face.
I'm, I, I don't regret a
day. There you go. I would,
if I had to do it again today,
I do it in a heartbeat.
And here's what happened was I was
an army reserve guy sold for full
transparency to your listeners.
Okay.
I was on active duty for five years.
I was on an army be service for 27 years.
Okay.
Now the army has three components.
They have the active component,
they had the army reserve and
they had the army national guard.
Okay.
The,
the army reserve and army national guard
or the so called reserve components.
Okay. Now, the active
army, of course, on the 24,
seven,
that's their full time job.
The army reserves are a federal force
and the army reserves fall into normal
army chain of command.
Department of the army.
We answered to the orders
of the president. Okay.
Army National Guard does not
fall into that chain of command,
nor do they report to the president,
baby port to the governors of each state.
It's really a state organization,
although 95% of their budget
comes from the federal government.
Okay.
Uh,
and as an Army reservist for 25 years,
27 years,
I saw whenever it came to,
uh,
reducing the army force structure,
the army reserves would always get the
short end and the guard would always be
protected. Okay. The actives would
always take care of themselves.
That was never an issue.
Okay.
But the soul called one army concept
where everybody's supposed to be together
in this, the reserves always
got the short end of the stick.
And the reason for that is the
reserves were a national force.
Okay. We were professional in, you know,
in the military, as, as you know,
you're not supposed to be political.
You're supposed to be apolitical,
right?
Not involved in lobbying
and stuff like that.
The National Guard is very political.
It's jobs for the state.
Okay.
So whenever there's,
the national guard has
so much political clout,
if you look at any,
uh,
presidential election just watched the
week before the election in November,
that's when the guard normally has
their national convention in DC.
Okay.
And I can tell ya,
every major presidential
candidate shows up.
Okay. And, and keep in mind,
they have the political support of a
governor to senators and the congressmen,
right? The army reserve doesn't have
that political clout. So frankly,
we've always gotten,
gotten screwed. And so I,
I watched that for 25 years.
I said, enough is enough.
And so I founded a five o one c three
organization called the Army Reserve
Association,
which was comprised of officers,
enlisted and civilians.
The mission was to educate the public
and Congress about the army reserves
because people, when they think
of, they hear of the reserves,
they think of the national guard,
they don't think of the army reserves,
which has armories and they have
soldiers in every state in our union.
But people don't think about that.
Okay.
So when Desert Storm ended,
right?
Uh,
when Desert Storm Hit,
the army mobilized both National
Guard and reserve units.
Okay. The national guard
had no full transparency.
As I said, I'm an army reserve guy. Okay.
So I'm pretty jaded on this.
You want to say that.
But you know,
the National Guard has great patriots.
I'm not casting aspersions
on, on dumb at all, you know,
but a facts are facts.
And here's what happened when,
when does the storm hit
the national guard heads,
three so-called called Premier Infantry
Brigades that were supposed to round out
active duty divisions. Okay. One of
them was the 48th out of Georgia.
Okay.
And there isn't a national guard
brigade that upon mobilization,
they would be assigned to that division
and they would go to war with the
division.
Okay.
And what happened was when it came,
and by the way,
they had all the best equipment,
they had better equipment than some
active army battalions and brigades.
They had Abrams tanks. You have to
understand this. The early nineties,
they had Abrams tanks and they had gladly
vehicles when a lot of active units
didn't have that.
Okay.
But they were publicized as being the
Premier Army National Guard combat units
that were ready to go to war.
Okay. When the balloon went up,
the army said, we can't send these guys.
They're just going to be cannon fodder.
So they sent them to the NTC,
the National Training Center in
California for 90 days. Okay.
Only problem was the war ended so quick.
They never got to the,
they never got there. All right.
The reserves on the other hand,
our soldiers perform magnificently. We had
helicopter units, we had medical units,
we had civil affairs, we had
psyops. We, uh, you know,
our, our people did extremely, my training
division. Perfect example. You know,
we were mobilized.
I had my guys in the front gates
of Fort Benning within 72 hours.
And my drill instructors
around the trail. My, my, uh,
uh, my, my, uh, instructors
are on the platform teaching,
you know,
running the rain
truths and all that.
And so then when it came time to downsize,
is that where you took a stand?
Yeah, absolutely. What happened
Ben, was that, you know, when the we,
so we wind up desert storm and then the
Soviet Union falls apart and the wall
comes down,
right?
So everybody's looking for this piece
of the night to transfer money from the
Defense Department to social services.
Okay.
And so the army has a process that's
called the total army analysis.
It's a very good logical process so you
can determine the force structure that
we need for the army.
Okay.
And the way it works is
you look at what are the,
what are we facing throughout the world?
You know,
what are the problem areas? And
then you say to yourself, okay,
based on that,
how many divisions do
infantry divisions do we need?
How many armored units, how
many helicopter battalion,
you know, blah, blah, blah.
And then you face reality and you say,
how much money can really
get out of Congress for this?
So based on all that stuff,
you come up with a force structure.
Okay.
The army didn't do that.
What they did is they had the
vice chief of staff of the army,
the chief of army reserves,
the chief of the National Guard Bureau,
the President of the
National Guard Association,
which is not a government group.
And the president of the Reserve Officers'
association go to a hotel and they
cut a deal and it was called the offsite
agreement because it wasn't done at the
Pentagon. Okay, well I told you I had
formed this Army Reserve Association.
All right?
I had people in that meeting within
five minutes I knew what happened.
And the army reserves really they,
they eliminated 80% of army reserve
aviation and we had four special forces
groups at that time in the
reserve components there are
to national guard groups,
the 19th and 20th and to army
reserve special forces groups.
The 11th and the 12th.
The 12th episode was one of the
units that I was under my command.
I was the deputy commanding
general of an army reserve unit.
So I'll give you an example.
We had a Black Hawk battalion once again
in my army reserve under my command
that fought in the golf.
They were so good that Schwarzkopf
selected them for his taxi unit.
Okay. And they had received, uh, the, uh,
it's called the Army
Aviation Association Award,
Aaa Award for the Best
Black Hawk battalion.
So that's how good these guys were.
Okay.
This agreement eliminated that unit out
of the army reserves and put it into the
Illinois National Guard.
Okay. No, I'm a big boy. I,
I can, I can accept, I don't
appreciate it as a taxpayer,
but I can accept waste
of money or whatever.
Where I draw the line in the sand is when
you jeopardize soldiers' lives and the
readiness of our forces.
Okay.
This unit overnight.
Oh,
what I didn't tell you was the Illinois
National Guard did not have one
qualified black hawk pilot or mechanics.
They could not even fly those birds from
Scott Air Force base where we had them
to the Illinois National Guard field.
They had to go to the Wisconsin and
Minnesota Guard to borrow pilots so they
could move those birds.
Now the implication is that
unit overnight went from c one,
you know, the highest rating
this rating down the SiFive,
which is non nondeployable basically,
you know,
and if it took about two B years plus
to get that unit up to c three which is
just marginal deployment level.
Okay? So that's one example.
Another example are those
special forces groups. Okay.
The army looked at the four reserve
components, special forces groups,
and they said, you know,
we only need two. Okay,
so we'll eliminate the
national guard, you know, uh,
groups because you know,
why does the National Guard govern?
Why does the governor need a Farsi
speaking demolitions expert? Okay.
In the last time I looked, we didn't
have an insurgency in Illinois. So,
so the National Guard says,
no, we don't accept that.
So the army with their tail between their
legs go back to the drawing board and
they looked at readiness,
which is what they probably
should have done to begin with.
And they found out that the 12th group
in the USA in the army reserves was the
best auto, the four.
And then it was either,
I think it was the 20th out of
the guard was the second best.
So they said, okay, we got to solution,
we'll take one out of each component.
Right.
Guard wouldn't accept that.
So what did they do?
They eliminated both army reserve,
you know,
groups.
And I was livid because the 12th
was under me at one time. Uh,
I wasn't the commander of a,
but it was in my chain.
We had taken that unit from c four to c
two which for a reserve unit to be able
to get reservist to pass those
special forces qualifications,
that's not easy. Okay. And
they eliminated that unit.
Now I'm a big boy.
Okay.
When it came like to the the
helicopter units and I said,
okay,
take my pilots and so and and mechanics,
take the reserve patch off their shoulder,
make a national guardsman,
I'm good with it.
Okay.
They wouldn't do it because
it was jobs for the guard.
So my guys had to find new jobs.
Some of them had to actually change a
molasses cause you know, there were no,
no aviation jobs for them.
Right.
And just think you and I as taxpayers,
how much that costs us, you know, so,
so now I'm getting all kinds
of calls from the field. Uh,
know we didn't have computers
at that time in the Internet.
So I'd get telephone calls
and faxes saying general,
somebody has got to stand
up and fight this, you know,
and that meeting I told
you about that they had,
I found out from my moles that in
essence they were going to have a press
conference the next day where everybody
was going to hold hands and sing Kumbaya
and say that the army has come up with
this great agreement where everybody
agrees and nobody disagrees.
While that wasn't true,
a lot of people disagreed with it.
So I called the vice chief of
staff's office at the Pentagon,
right.
Not as Major General Jim [inaudible],
but as Jim [inaudible], President
Army Reserve Association. Okay.
So I call asking for a
return call about this,
this press conference, it's going
to happen or announcement, you know,
and I didn't get a call back.
So the next morning,
an hour before their press conference,
we sent out a press release
and we basically said, this is
not good. This is, you know,
shouldn't go through,
need to have a Gao study of government
accounting office study. Uh,
and that pretty well got
me into the crosshairs.
And so then what we did is,
and now we keep in mind,
I had never done this in my
life. I'd never lobbied. I
had never been to Congress.
I had never walked the halls, you
know, any of that stuff. We had a,
we actually, and I think I might've sent
you some of this stuff, but we had a, a,
a meeting of the Army Reserve
Association called for in Washington DC.
And I had men and women come from all
over the country and we went and we
lobbied our senators and congressmen
and we told them, this is wrong.
This needs to,
the needs to be a g o state.
It needs to be studied before it's
implemented. Okay. Now, frankly,
I knew we were tilting at windmills,
but I had to do it because, you know,
all I was getting all these bequest from
sergeants and civilians and lieutenants
and majors throughout the country saying,
somebody got to fight
this and they were right.
So I had to do it some.
Then I get an invitation from
a congressional subcommittee.
Okay. It was not a subpoena, so I
didn't have to go, I could have set,
I've got a headache or I've got a conflict
or whatever, but I didn't, you know,
I said, yeah, I'll be there.
And I went and I testified,
and a year later I was history,
shall we say,
but it's a, like I said, Jocko, I,
I wouldn't hesitate in a
moment to do it again. Uh,
it's when I was in Vietnam,
I knew that our generals for not
standing up for us all the time like they
should.
And I said,
ever get to a point in life where it's
the difference between my career and,
and my soldiers,
the soldiers when,
yeah, perhaps a ruby. And that's one of
those balance things too, is you know,
as a leader where you know,
you, you want to tow the line.
And I have people ask me this
pretty regularly. Well, you know,
you always say you want a sport,
the chain of command,
but with the chain of command is
wrong. Well, it's real simple answer.
If the chain of command is wrong
and it's something that matters,
like the safety of your troops, the
training of your troops, then you,
you stand up to it, you
know, if it's something that
doesn't matter for, they go,
oh, we want you to fill out this paperwork
differently than you did it yesterday.
You know what I do? I do it
right. I don't care. You know,
you want me to put my uniform on this
way instead of that way? That's fine.
Whatever.
I'll do it.
You want to start putting soldiers a
jeopardy that won't, that won't stand.
So here's what happened. Okay.
While all this stuff is going on,
the Washington Post puts this front
page and it talks about how the,
the, uh, this big controversy,
you know, in my associations,
right at the forefront of all the, so
I'm quoted in all it. Now keep in mind,
I am still an active army reserve,
major general that trade on life.
And, and in fact, before I testified,
I got a call from the chief of staff at
trade. Doc was a good friend of mine.
We're both major generals and,
and uh,
he didn't tell me I shouldn't go. He
kind of said that, well, you know,
it's really not a good idea,
you know, for you to go.
And he was a good friend of mine
and I said, John, you know, I,
I understand this is, you
have to do this, this is your,
this is your job, but
I got to go. I can't,
I cannot stand by and
let this pass. So, uh,
he under, well, and so that was
also Linda Washington folks.
Like I was threatened, I wasn't
threatened, you know, and so,
so basically,
uh,
I then the army times wrote an editorial
which basically criticized the army
reserves, especially my
association, you know,
and saying the army reserves are
not team players. They're crybabies,
you know,
and but what got me is when they said
they're putting out bad information. Okay.
That was in their editorial.
Okay. So I wrote an op Ed.
Okay.
Which to their credit they published or
claim and in the op Ed I said number one
where is,
and the title of their,
their editorial was the enemy is us.
Okay.
And I said, I agree
with you, the enemy us.
But the problem is number one,
where is you didn't list in detail the
false information that was being put up
by the reserves. So you need to
do that. I said that in the op Ed,
they never did by the way, because
we had never put out anything false.
But the second thing I said,
and I said,
if we go to war in the next 18
months and this thing goes through,
we're going to have people coming
back in body bags that would not have,
I mean, now that's a pretty serious
statement, isn't dude. Okay.
And you would think if I was chicken
little saying the sky was falling,
that they would have been inundated with
letters from the field saying yield.
The general's gone too far.
Right? They didn't get one letter.
And so, but so because of the
stand I took, needless to say,
the army wasn't real happy with me.
And a year later when it came time to,
uh,
to get a new assignment,
a surprise, surprise,
I was not considered a, there were
no assignments that I was, uh,
considered eligible for. And so
I, I said, this has been fun.
So the chief of army reserve
actually wanted me to stay. Uh,
and he said, this too shall
pass, so why don't you stay,
you can go into control group,
which is kind of this administrative pool
of people who don't have assignments.
And maybe in a year or two
you can come back, you know,
we'll get you an assignment. And
I said, no. I said, you know,
the army's made it very clear, you
know, they don't want my services,
they don't think I have any
value and I'm going to move on.
I got to move on in life.
And No. So what I did
now, even though you
moved on, he retired, uh,
you didn't stop serving by any
stretch. And, and you know,
I look at the military outreach that
you started is really your new way of
serving it. Was that, is
that an accurate statement?
Oh, absolutely. What, what
happened was, you know,
my wife is so wonderful, she,
she said she's not as, as,
as a Christian as I am,
but she lives her life better than I do.
And so I'm having my personal pity
party feeling sorry for myself,
cause my 32 year career is down
the toilet. Right. And she said,
Jim, you know, God is sending
you a message, number one,
that you know, this chapter in your
life is over. Okay. Number two,
you survived Vietnam.
You also became attained the
rank of two star general,
which was the highest of reservists
could get at that time. Okay.
And then she says, number three,
and you've got me as a wife,
how can I argue with that? Right?
But she was absolutely right.
What happened was God brought other
things into my life. At that time,
a promise keepers, which was
a men's Christian group. Uh,
I got, uh, involved with
a church in Chicago. Oh,
Willow Creek community church, which
was a very famous evangelical church. I,
I led a men's small group.
I lead a men's monthly breakfast.
I got involved with the
Department of Veterans Affairs,
which I had never been involved
in before at a national level. Uh,
I was a chairman of an advisory
committee on minority veterans and I was,
uh,
I was on that for five years.
So I learned about the VA system.
Uh,
all of this was in preparation for me to
eventually start military outreach USA
about seven years ago.
Uh,
which is a nonprofit faith
based organization. Uh,
for the very simple concept.
Jocko.
We're trying to develop a
national network of partners,
mostly houses of worship of
all faiths by the way. Uh,
and organizations like, uh, the VFW,
American Legion, Rotary Clubs,
lions clubs, highschools.
This is all at the local community level
that will reach out to our military
community, which we defined by
the way is active duty reserves,
national guard veterans of all
eras and their family members.
We stressed the family members equally
because they serve and sacrifices well.
Okay.
And to reach out to them,
to be a welcoming environment,
to appreciate their service,
recognize that and to offer
hope and help if they need it.
Now the churches and
synagogues want to help.
They don't know how to do it because they
don't understand the military culture.
They don't know the issues
that our military community
is facing and they don't
know where the resources are. That's
where military outreach USA comes in.
We provide all of that information.
We have webinars,
we have publications,
we have DVDs,
we have presentations,
and everything that we do
is free of charge, no cost.
The only thing we ask is when people
join us as partners either as a house of
worship or as an organization that they
commit to take our materials and use
them to help our military community.
It doesn't cost them anything.
And if people want to want to help out
military outreach USA and though the
website is military outreach usa.org.
That's correct. And then from
what, what are you looking
for?
Well we have numerous programs.
See Cause we understand houses of
worship come in all shapes and sizes.
Okay. So we have different
programs that they can choose from.
Some are as simple as uh,
a church can list the names of service
members who are currently serving,
you know,
either relatives or,
or members of the church and
people can pray for them.
Prayer is so important
when you're overseas,
especially in a combat situation.
I know it helped me a lot
when I was in combat. Uh,
I needed all I could
get, I'll tell Ya. Uh,
but also they could do
things like send packages,
send letters today who writes
letters? Nobody, you know,
it was all email and all that stuff.
How about getting a letter right
at mail call? How neat is that?
Uh, you know, uh, but then we can
also do things for veterans. Uh,
in fact, we, we have, uh,
two years ago we started a program.
And by the way,
we have a memorandum of agreement that
was signed by the Department of Veterans
Affairs in 2016 by the secretary himself,
which recognize military outreach USA
as a national partner with them on a
program that we initiated called
veteran's exiting homelessness.
Okay. Now here's the thing. Uh,
the Va has done a very good job in
reducing the veteran homeless population.
It's still too high. But three years
ago it was like 150,000, you know,
it's like 50,000 now, which is
still too high. But look at the,
look at the reduction. Okay, well
that's created a new problem.
And the problem is when they
take a homeless veteran,
male or female,
some with kids off the street and they
work with a case worker or a social
worker.
Okay.
And the social worker feels that they're
stabilized and now they can get him
into what is called permanent housing,
which is really an apartment.
That's God. It's subsidized
by a Hud vash voucher. Okay.
They give them the keys to the
apartment. Right. But homeless people,
that's all they give them. So Jessica, the
first time you moved into an apartment,
yeah. Needs stuff. Lysol
toilet paper buckets.
Uh, sponges, mops, uh, you know, dishes.
How about a bed? Homeless people?
They get a one bedroom apartment,
but guess what? They
don't have a bed. Right.
So we came up with this program called
move in essentials and we listed things
like we have a bathroom kit,
we have a kitchen kit,
we even have a beds for vets program.
Okay.
And what we've done is we've
gone out to our, our churches,
our partners, you know,
organizations and we've asked him,
can you conduct a donation
drive of this stuff? Okay.
And not asking them collect
money gimme the stuff. Okay.
And then it's delivered
to the Va Medical Center,
social worker,
and they distribute it to the veterans.
So we know they're going to
veterans. Okay. Cause you know,
there are a lot of people out there
who clean to be veterans who are not.
And so we know they're going to veterans
and it goes out almost as quick as it
comes in.
Okay.
This has helped us a great deal
as an organization because before,
uh,
we're,
we're at a point in time where we really
can move up to the next level as an
organization,
but we frankly need volunteers and money.
Okay. Cause we don't have a staff. We'd
done all this on a shoestring basically.
And so,
uh,
with this program we now have
results that we can show people.
Okay. So people come to
me and say, Jim, you know,
what difference are you guys making?
Two years ago,
all I could say was while we're developing
this network of partners and we're
asking numb to help, you know, in their
communities, which did make a difference,
by the way.
I mean we prevented some suicides.
We've helped people that needed stuff,
you know,
but we did the have,
I didn't,
I don't have the staff to record
all of this stuff, you know, button.
When we came up with this program,
we have a tracking thing where we know
how many veterans are being helped.
We know what's been collected and we know.
So now if somebody says, what
difference do you make? Okay.
Since January of 2016 we have
helped over 31,000 veterans.
We've collected over 750,000 items.
In fact,
I think it's over a million now
and valued at almost $2 million.
And we have,
we just provided this month our 1000 bed.
Okay. Uh, and so now I've got stuff
that I can tell people this. Well,
we've come up with a new program this
year and has called adopt a caregiver.
Okay.
See what we're trying to do is fine.
Find gaps where there's a need
and nobody else is filling it.
So we first we did that veterans
exiting homelessness thing.
Well now there are 5.5 million
military caregivers in our country.
Okay.
Serving over 1.1 million
milled former military.
Okay.
And they get some help from the VA
but not a lot as much as they need.
Okay.
So we are now going to our churches and
our organizations and we're saying we
have this program adopt a caregiver.
Okay.
And if you want to be a caregiver,
you let us know and we'll
contact the local social worker,
volunteer support at the
Va facility near you.
And we'll hook you up with
a caregiver that needs help.
Now this could be anything. It could
be babysitting, could be mowing along,
it could be shoveling snow,
it could be a showing up with a meal.
It could be just showing up and being
there for three hours and let the
caregiver get a break.
Okay.
This is not rocket scientist stuff.
It's an easy program,
but it's something that if we can get
this moving like we did the veterans
succeeding homelessness, it's going to
be a tremendous help for our veterans.
And but most importantly for the
caregivers you see on an another lifetime,
my wife and I were hospice
patient volunteers.
We did that for six years.
So I know how it is to deal
with a terminal illness.
Okay.
But I also witnessed that it's the
caregivers who are sometimes need to help
more than the patient,
you know?
And so in this case we've got military
caregivers that need help and we can do
it through this program.
Well it sounds like,
like I said,
you're continuing to serve even
though you're no longer in uniform.
And I think that's probably a pretty
good place to wrap up for today.
And you know,
again,
it's been just an absolute honor to
sit down and talk with you as we get
feedback from this episode.
I will come to Chicago
and go to your museum and,
and we'll do this again.
Yeah,
let me,
let me say one thing that able to get in
and anybody who knows me would tell me,
Jim, why didn't you say that?
I have a standard mantra. Okay.
And that is every day is a great day.
I have my faith,
my family, and live in the
finest country in the world.
I see it every day, every chance
I got. And people ask me, well,
why? You know, how can you be so positive
and you know, why do you say that? I say,
well,
number one,
as a very young 24 year old company
commander in Vietnam in combat,
there were times I didn't know if I
was going to be alive the next moment,
much less seed and next sunrise.
When you're in those circumstances,
what is important in life becomes
real focused. And that is faith,
family and living in the finest
country in the world now.
So Zen people will come
back at me and say,
well how can you say that when we have
so much division in our country? Okay.
And I say, listen, I'm a little
bit longer in tooth than you are.
And when I was a kid,
the,
I've seen the improvements in our
society when it comes to race relations.
Now I'm a minority. So I
get it. And I told them the,
the odds of me becoming,
when I was a kid,
the odds of me becoming a major journal
in the United States army were slimming
next to none. Okay. When you know,
when we've had an African American
president who was reelected,
and then I tell people when
President Kennedy was elected,
that was a big deal. And, and
a lot of people don't know why.
And I say because he was Catholic,
but today that that's, that's,
that's not a big deal. Right. And that,
that though in those
days that was a big deal.
So I tell people every day is a great
day. I have my faith, my family,
we live in the finest
country in the world. Well,
that saying was challenged about five
and a half years ago when I had some
health challenges,
which I think I didn't mention it
earlier than a writer you ever. Uh,
I was still working in a
financial services industry
and I got up in the morning
or shaving and I felt
this pain in my chest.
And I mean, it wasn't a serious
pounding and I wasn't sweating,
nausea, so I didn't have a temperature.
So, uh, I thought it was something I ate,
you know, give it five minutes, it'll
go away. Right. It didn't go away.
So I told my wife, this is not good.
So I finished shaving and dressing. No,
and she drove me to the emergency room
at the hospital. So I walk in and I say,
Hey, you know, I've got this pain in
my chest. I don't know what it is.
So they do an EKG and they said,
you have had a heart attack.
Well, suddenly all these doctors
and nurses swoop into the Er,
they undress me and they put me in
a hospital gown amount of Gurney,
and I'm on my way to the operating room,
right?
So I'm in the corridor and on this
Gurney and I say to myself, self,
can you say today is a great day?
And I said, I absolutely can.
I survive Vietnam.
I have a wonderful wife and children
and I most importantly have my faith.
So in 24 hours I had three operations.
The first operation was for the heart
attack. Okay. Say do an angiogram.
They found out my LDD,
which is the widow maker artery,
was 90% blocked. So they do an
angioplasty, put a stent in.
So by 10 o'clock in the
morning, I'm a Newbie. Cover
your room sign figuring. Well,
that's, that's the end of it,
right? That wasn't the end of it.
The second thing that happened was my
heart cavity started to fill up with
liquid, it's called a fusion.
So I had to go back in for an,
they had to put a hole in my chest so
they could put a tube there so they could
drain this liquid and
it filled up a bottle.
It took about 24 hours to do that.
Okay.
The third thing that happened
then was my kidneys failed,
so I had to go back in and they had to
put another hole in my chest so they
could hook up a day dialysis machine.
Okay.
So the standard procedure,
every time I was rolled into the
operating room is, what's your name?
What's your birthday?
How do you feel? Okay,
so I'm on the operating table
and I say Jim Mcclean Yama,
August 3rd 44 every day is a great day.
I have my faith,
my family, and live in the
finest country in the world.
I can't tell you the effect that
had on the doctors and nurses.
The first operation, the doctor said,
what is your faith? And I said, well,
since you asked me doc, I said, I'm
a Christian. Christ is my savior.
You're a skilled physicians, skilled
nurses, but I'm in God's hands.
So whatever he decides I'm okay with,
so let's get on with it.
So the second operation there
was a nurse and she said,
where do you go to
church? And I said, well,
I attend Willow Creek Community Church.
And she said,
I do too. So no coincidence,
the third operation,
this was the coolest thing.
There was a male nurse who
is wearing a camouflage gone.
And I said, you must have been in the
army, nick. I said, yeah, I was a medic.
And I said, well, Hey, I just want you to
know I've retired as a two star general,
so take good care of me,
William.
And so that was kind of my testing of,
of all that.
Now the final thing I'll tell you,
which was a god thing,
a month later I was going,
I had to go through dialysis.
Okay,
so I'm going through this dialysis and
and three months later I get a donor and
the donor was our daughter.
Okay.
But our daughter is not
our biological daughter.
We adopted her 30 something years
ago and yet she was a match.
So guys,
when I say every day is a great day,
I have my faith, my family, and live in
the kind of finest country in the world.
I can truly say that.
And every day,
every day is an encouragement to me.
Okay?
Today was an encouragement this morning
when I was honored to participate in the
National Day of prayer with the 79
the theater sustainment command at Los
Alamitos. And this podcast
is an encouragement to me.
So I just want you to know that you
don't remember, every day is a great day.
Faith family. We live in the
finest country in the world.
Well,
sir,
even though this is my podcast and
I'm supposed to talk after that,
I don't really have anything else to say.
Thank you so much for coming on.
It's been a complete honor to have you
and I look forward to doing this again at
some point in the future.
Thank you so much and the general has
left the building and we have actually
relocated back to our recording studio
and just amazing opportunity and
definitely thanks to thanks
to Jay Uchiyama for connecting
us and send a little
gift to you as well,
so thanks for,
thanks for putting this together
with your dad and echo. Yes.
Speaking of putting things together,
yes.
If somebody wanted to put
together something for
themselves and maybe something
that would, you know it's
porch. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Could you brief us on those things?
Namely your joints.
Do you want to keep those together
because it's a big deal if they're not
together, so good news if you
didn't, all right already,
even though you didn't know already.
Jocko supplements,
they're called Jocko
Super Krill Krill oil,
but that's not in the name.
Technically. Also Jocko joint warfare,
also free joints obviously
take both of them.
There's some anti-inflammatory
stuff in there too, by the way.
Something that I might've
mentioned before. Anyway,
for you join. It's very good.
Very important.
Subscribe for the the recurring delivery.
Yeah,
cause you don't want to run out.
I'm telling you it's junk when you run
out everyone out before it's whack.
I'm also disciplined supplement called
discipline. It is a pre workout,
pre mission, pre study, pre take tests,
pre cognitive enhancing supplements.
Good. This is a good one.
Pre get after it and it tastes good.
Interestingly enough,
Jocko focused a lot on that. Tastes
good. Lemon, lime, et Cetera, et cetera.
How many calories in this one?
I Dunno. Not, not very many.
30 alright, there you go.
So you can do it while you fast too.
Technically.
Depends on your metabolic response.
Look into it before you fast.
I'm not going to make any claims. None
the less. It's a good one for your brain.
For your body. Good supplement. Also milk.
Yeah. So I'm was going to
say, let me, teen powder.
So milk, protein powder. Do you, are you,
are we even calling it protein powder or
are we just calling this trade out more?
It's not, it's milk. Straight up.
More with them lots. Yeah. Yeah.
So that is chocolate chip
mint chocolate chips.
There's no chips. Yeah. Yeah. So if you
don't like mint chocolate chip, you might,
there's a chance you might not like this.
If you do like mint chocolate chip,
there's a real good job.
Like I would say around 100% probability
you're going to like this one.
I should clarify that.
I mix it primarily with milk.
Me Too.
I have mixed it also plain with wealth.
Not playing, but with cold water. Yeah,
it's with milk.
It's straight up delicious.
It's like it's a milk straight up. It's
a milkshake. You like, Oh, what? What?
What do I truly in the world want to
have for dessert? I want to have milk.
Right.
With water,
it's more like a ham sandwich.
You Sir. You know like,
okay, hey, this thing is good. I, you
know, I need some fuel. You don't,
you don't get all fired up when you have
a ham sandwich, right? Yeah. You're not.
You're not, you're not reaching the next
level. You're happy. You're not fired up.
That's kind of what my milk with
water is like a ham sandwich.
It's better for you,
but tastes, tastes. Um,
reaction is about the same
for me. Ham Sandwich. Okay.
With, with milk. So it's, it's legit.
What is it like a what
like a state states.
It's like a stately comparatively boom.
Jockos review on law.
Well official actually no it's not.
It's like a mint chocolate chip milkshake.
That's what it's like. Yeah. Because
the steak is a different thing for me.
Steak is a little bit of a
different experience. That's
a really good experience.
So technically you can't
replace steak. No, no.
But if you look at the
last fast I did and I,
and I posted that picture
and I went and got that.
I went and got a killer stake and I think
it was so good because he did it after
the fact. So good. Yeah. So you got
100% of the tastes, 100% of the tastes.
No more than 100% of the country.
10%
somebody sent me some Tomahawk
steaks to my house and they came with
instructions from the company that sent
them on how to cook them. And I'll,
I don't remember the name of the company
right now. I follow those instructions.
I cook those steaks. Hmm.
Those things were APIC. Yeah,
they were epic. Yeah.
So interestingly, yeah,
no stakes came to my house
or anything like that.
Or you need a houses next to mine,
but hey,
they do sound good and they sound even
better after cause currently we're
getting our fast on. Yes.
Currently. Officially to, yeah.
What are we at right now?
Wow. Well I you, I'm a,
I'm a 23 hours or something right now
and I think I'm at like 18 right now was
good. Do you need an 11 o'clock last
night? Yeah. You gotta issues. That's not,
what are you doing eating
the 11 o'clock at night?
Because like I don't really start eating
till like later in the day he said I
don't eat breakfast.
Like you see them playing though late,
let's say eat three meals a day.
And that's not a lot by the way.
That's actually a little bit, you know,
some kinds of it. Six Times d, You know,
that kind. Not like that guy
three times a day. Sometimes two.
So let's say I ate my first
meal, no breakfast, only water,
maybe some coffee, sometimes, maybe some
Gatorade, something maybe like a banana,
sometimes not a lot.
Nonetheless at noon Ish,
one maybe to lunch,
dinner aid in a like six boom and
then again at 11 that's normal.
That's not that much. Do what you
want to do over there. Nonetheless,
I'm at about 18 hours.
Give or take.
And that state that you
were just talking about,
the Tomahawk one sounds real good.
Better because right now real fired up.
By the way.
You didn't even mention where you
can get all this good stuff. We'll,
there's even more good stuff.
So what I,
what I like to do is like get us real
excited about everything and then it's
like Dang, where can
you get it? Boom origin.
I do want to say we have in
the testing phase right now,
chocolate, peanut butter, milk, milk.
Now everyone's probably
wondering, Hey, what's up?
What's up with just
chocolate milk? Yeah. We,
for whatever reason, I don't know if
it's the complimentary of flavors,
but we haven't been able to
nail the chocolate flavor
the way we want it at this
time. Yeah. Yeah. The the men, I don't
know. You know the men is awesome.
The chocolate peanut butter APIC. Yeah.
We haven't nailed the chocolate yet.
We got vanilla, the Vanilla's.
I'm not a vanilla fan,
but the vanilla's good.
I can't,
I can't give it nine stars because I,
I can't give nine stars.
Two things that I don't personally really
love the taste of because I don't love
vanilla.
I'll try it again once it,
once we roll out with the
actual live vanilla milk,
but the chocolate milk
Wilcom when we get it right,
but the peanut butter milk
stand by to get some make sense.
Isn't that the whole kind of defining
factor of the vanilla flavor? It's like,
it's not supposed to be amazing.
It's supposed to be vanilla.
Like people use the word vanilla.
This guy, let me tell you,
I actually, let me tell you when, when,
when I do absolutely love vanilla flavor.
You know when you go to a restaurant
and you're like, all right,
tonight we're going to get some and use
her order dessert and you get some kind
of a chocolate scenario.
Let's say, let's just,
let's just talk about a chocolate as
hot chocolate Brownie, right? Yeah.
You roll up one of those.
So there's uh, the, my,
my local one of my local restaurants,
they have a dessert,
they call it the legal cause it's so good.
It should be illegal.
This is Ragland Ragland ob and what it is,
they take a cast iron skillet and they
put a chocolate chip cookie in there.
And then, and I, I, when they make it
for us, we don't get it. I don't know.
Once every two months we'll go illegal
time and that extra ice cream cause you
need it. Cause it's got that chocolate,
it's hot. It's so good. And you know what,
I just realized we're on a 24
hour fast right now. All dog food.
I'm like Dang,
this is taken kind of long.
But it kind of don't mind it cause that,
and you're right about that vanilla thing
too, by the way, because people do, well,
people do use the word violet vanilla
to describe a real big old other bland
vanilla, which is, you know,
it's not great, but it's not,
John could still borrow cast iron skillet.
You're 100% right. Especially when
you said when you go to a restaurant.
I was like, Bro, I know where you're going
with this. And you're absolutely right.
So that being said,
so what do you do then?
You put some chocolate like
Hershey's syrup in the vanilla milk.
That's a violation, Huh?
Boy, that'd be a big file.
It just sounds real good right now.
I'm just, that's why nonetheless,
the illegal, it should be illegal
for us to Duke I've been on,
I've been fasting before
and on the podcast,
but this is different when I know that
you're headed in the same boat and this
is kind of like, uh, usually
I'm just cruising at home.
Like I didn't done it before for sure,
but it was crazy at home and it's
like boom. But now like, yeah,
once you get to talking
about it, shoot, then I,
and I got to drive by
Wendy's on the way home.
Something check.
Either way you get all this stuff,
vanilla milk, not right now. Uh, chocolate
peanut butter milk now, right now,
chocolate mint, mint chocolate
right now, right now.
And we go home and have one origin
main.com that's where you get it. Boom.
And all the others, the Jocko, Super
Krill that that is like everyday stuff.
You gotta take that one every day, get
on the subscription thing. But these,
you know all this other stuff after
all of it, like I said, all of it.
Origin main.com also at origin mean,
I'll tell you what there's on,
there is geese for Jujitsu,
very important.
When you start Jujitsu or if you already
started, you just, you need a gay.
People still ask and I'm glad they do
because I have the answer for him. What?
Gee Do I get? I started, did
you see what he do? I get,
sometimes I ask the color and
that's a whole different question,
but they say what brand of key,
here's the brand origin brand,
100% made in America best.
These are the gies that like Pete
and all that. When they make them,
they take into consideration
all the movements of Jujitsu,
like everything even down
to this and think about it,
we might not even have thought about it
like outside of when you put this on.
Okay, so in a regular gay, they have the
string to tie on the pants, not the mill,
the string on the fence. Then you have
a belt that goes over the, the gay top,
all that stuff. No, that string
fine. We're used to it and fine.
It's a cool stream,
but you ever like put in the dryer where
it got caught on something or whatever
and that string gets lost in the
little too. I didn't even know you,
but you see what I'm saying?
Right.
Like project Hoodie happen to your Hoodie
and you've got to get the hanger and
you've got to do this big thing.
If you even know how otherwise you're
kind of screwed in a way cause you gotta
go all up in there.
Now take the origin gay.
These are just these details that when
you get someone who's thinking of this
kind of stuff, when they
designed the whole Geek, you
got some [inaudible] there.
This is one of the many reasons why
you get the origin. Get this one,
the string comes out.
That's okay because it's not this,
this endless black hole
loop holder tunnel.
Use names in.
Yeah.
It's like it'll have like a giant
thick wide belt loops. Yeah.
And a bunch of them too. So
you have like, you know, it's,
it's so easy to put them in.
That's even if you even want the string.
If you don't want the string,
you're like, Hey, I'm over strings.
I don't like tying my string.
They give you this little bell and
you'll see if you have origin Gig,
you're like, Ooh. Yeah,
exactly. Exactly right. Yeah.
Well it's a belt.
It's a teeny,
it's a thin belt that goes through
and click you click the belt,
make it tight or whatever. It's
like a little mini belt. You don't,
you don't feel it when you're rolling.
Nothing like that.
Did you think you're going to feel it
when you were old? It was a question.
There wasn't enough
thought. I've, you know,
this seems kind of weird and
then you put it on and you don't,
you don't notice it.
You don't notice until it comes time
to take it off and it's so easy. Yeah.
You're like boom.
And here's the thing again,
it's like we probably never really
thought of this until you actually do it.
Like Akron, when you're,
when you're done doing it,
you don't really think about it,
but it's just one of those things
where it's like, Dang, this is good,
these are good, these are good keys.
One of the many details. Yes. Who did,
I was talking to a guy yesterday,
I was getting interviewed and I said,
yeah. I said, well, you know, he's asking
me about all my different businesses,
right? Whatever that means, all
opinion. And I said, well, you know, I,
I have a apparel company and we make,
we make apparel up in Maine. Got a
big factory up in Maine. He says, oh,
up in Maine, that's up in Maine
factory in Maine. And you know what?
I was like, yeah. And he was all
surprised. And I said, you know what?
It's sad that you're surprised
at that because 50 years ago,
everybody knew that that's
where they made stuff.
They made it up there
and it all disappeared.
And now it's coming back and we're
bringing it back. I told this guy,
we're bringing it back. We're bringing
back made. In fact, we've got,
we're weaving material up there.
When you don't know what that,
we didn't even know what
I'm talking about. People's
first instinct is like, Oh,
if you want material, you've got to
go to overseas and you got to have,
you've got to get it, get it made
in some sweatshop somewhere. Right.
That's literally what, that's, that's,
that's accepted, right. That's accessible.
Like, Oh, you just, you know, hey, you
can't beat those prices and you can't,
you can't overcome the, the tariffs
and whatever else. No. You know what?
Yes you can. Yes you can. And we
are. Yep. We're doing it. Yeah.
He gets the cotton in like North Carolina.
You're screwing up South Carolina.
I believe I'm screwing it up
to get the cotton in America.
One of the current in America. The
thing is that, just talk to peanut,
I'm pretty sure he said north could
have been south. I don't know. I forget.
Can I apologize?
Nonetheless it is in just like you said,
and then they bring it up and
here's what it is. Who the secret.
They have their looms.
They have their own looms.
You can't just walk into a store and start
buying looms. You just can't do that.
That's why it's hard to,
you know, to kind of,
that's why they have a unique situation
there where it's all made in America.
Perfect. Everyone that is
supporting us at origin. Thank you.
Cause right now you know what we're doing.
We're expanding,
we're buying more machines,
we're buying better equipment
and we're hiring more people.
So thank you for your
support. It's awesome. We're,
we're only able to bring manufacturing
back to America because of you knowing
that you want to have the best and you
want it made America. So thanks everyone.
Thank you fucking that much appreciated.
But yeah,
that's the one origin main.com. A lot
of cool stuff on there. Some hoodies,
not to mention the most comfortable
pants in the world officially now.
Officially I'm wearing right now. We go to
la today. Good, fine. You know, whatever.
But you're gonna want to
wear something comfortable.
This is my thought process before we
went to where the most comfortable thing
that I own. Straight up. No
question. Me. Origin Pants, boom.
Anyway, also, like I
said, Geez, rash guards,
compression gear and whatnot.
Anyway,
just go there or do you mean.com
get what you want. Also,
the immersion camps did Jujitsu camp,
you did sue immersion camp,
not concentration camp. Not,
not a necessarily a summer camp.
Not Band camp. Not Band camp. No,
it's like an emerging k immerse yourself
and you did it to you train as much or
as little as you want, but you get to be
in Jujitsu the whole time. Boom. One week,
two sessions. You can do both if you
want. By the way, Jack will be there.
I will be there. Maybe not at full
capacity. That jury's still out of.
Now we're going to see you
about some stuff. Long story,
Dave Burke Lafe looks like j p work in it.
Anyway. A lot of cool fun people will be
there. It's going to be a good good time.
Um, if last year is any indicators
can be real good time. Also,
if you want to vary up your workout, you
want to get some kettlebells, like some,
someone just texted me today. Well
you know, and on DM, right online.
What weight Kettlebell should
I use? Okay, here's the thing.
That's a broad question. So who
are you exactly right? Yeah.
It's an easy answer. I
didn't think so. Order,
the 48 kilogram ones can potentially
kill yourself or smash it on your tool
because you can hold it or it's too
light for you. I Dunno. It just depends.
So it depends on how much you know
about using kettlebells. Defense,
the how strong you are.
Depends on how big you are and
it depends on what kind of,
yeah, no, this kind of, it does. No,
it depends on what kind of fitness
you're trying to achieve. Yeah, it, yes,
because goals are trying to get big and
strong or you want to get a bigger crowd
belt. Yeah. We're trying to get more,
more metcon, conditioning and whatnot.
Then you get maybe a smaller carryable
yeah, maybe medium or something like that.
The last point is, hey, it depends.
Depends, but here's the thing.
I will say this,
I'm gonna say this with complete bias
because I cause the Onnit kettle bells on
it. Those are the kettle bells you
get regardless of what size you get.
The artsy primal bell ones,
that's, and that's the one you get.
They're just way cooler.
Also,
if you want to vary. We were work.
Like I said, no boring workouts.
Jocko doesn't have borne
workouts apparently thought
he did. He doesn't. I know.
But do you want to make your workouts
interesting? Different movements,
functional strength and actual strength.
There's other stuff on there starting
with like, oh it's a spectrum.
It goes from jump ropes all the way up
to mate steel bells with the steel bell.
They look like a Frisbee. Right.
But there's filled with metal.
But would he do with them? All kinds
of stuff. Right. You see there,
that's the point. So there's a
bunch of stuff on there anyway.
A lot of good stuff. Let a, um, what
did I just get that were pretty cool?
Oh the stocks boom on it. Socks on
it straight up. So there's a lot of,
a lot of cool stuff on there on there.
A lot of good information on there too.
So a lot of the questions that are
directed at me, I don't know the answer.
I sometimes don't know the answer for
me as opposed to me. Some stuff I heard,
but it's real flimsy a lot of the time.
You got a on it and let
information on there, so get some,
as they say on it.com/jocko good way
to support. If you want something,
get something. Also, when you get these
books that Jocko reviews, sometimes
Hackworth books about face. Good
one, steal my soldiers hearts.
Good on any of the books.
Feel the need to get one.
Hate to wherein it organized
all the books by episode Jocko,
podcast.com go Jocko, podcast.com click
on the top books from episodes. Boom,
I got them organized perfectly.
Click through there. Get your book,
get whatever book you want to
get. Two books, get a leaf.
Lord, just continue. Shit.
Just go. Just do your Amazon thing and
you're all good. Good way to support.
Also subscribe to the podcast. If you
haven't already on iTunes, stitcher,
Google play podcast,
Pod, bean pod, this pod,
cast apps out there. Just so subscribe
to the podcast, what I'm saying,
that's kind of the thing. Regardless of
what podcast application you're using,
it's good way to support the review if
you're in the mood to just leave a review.
You know when you kind of think about it,
if you're not in the mood to lever,
if you, I don't even know
if it's conducive to leave
a review or is it, I dunno.
I said go for it. Yeah. I
say go for it. BTF BTF right.
I say if you're in the mood, leave review
to you. Also, we have a youtube channel.
If you didn't already the
subscribed to that one.
That's a good way to support as well.
We have excerpts on there.
Try to post every day.
Try to sometimes two a day.
Try to also on there is enhanced excerpts.
You know what I mean by that?
I know what you mean by
cinematography into the scenarios you
film and then you edit with music and
other special effects, CGI and
whatnot. Sure. Well at the very least,
I'll put some music on there.
You know,
making things are exploding sometimes.
Sometimes you read it,
the warpath videos,
so there's no longer a horrible
Christmas. No is a deliverable. See,
I'd put Christmas music on that
cause it was Christmas time.
Don't ever do that again.
You want to get Christmas spirit,
watch the watch the Christmas 1914 video.
That's a good one as well.
And that's better Christmas spirit
is real Christmas spirit. Yeah.
Nonetheless. That's why I did it. But
look, you make a good point. Hey, what?
Whatever. You never put Christmas
music and one of my, uh,
what do they call excerpts?
Oh, now that yours. Okay.
If I'm in it,
please don't put Christmas
music in our excerpts.
You got it. I promise. Yeah,
I got to take down actually.
All right. Hey, I dig it and you know,
thought he's not going to be Christmas
every day. The wise man once said,
it's not Christmas every day.
So why put Christmas music on something
that someone might may or may not listen
to every day? So I understand. So yeah.
Or we did it, you know, revamp some stuff,
sometimes stuff.
Put some different music on that if
you want to listen to it everyday. Fyi,
my wife completely stuck up for
you on that one. Yeah. Because, oh,
it's nice Christmas music. It was
released at Christmas time. Okay.
I just went into like hiding.
It was kind of a bummer too
because that was a really,
I know you put a lot of time and effort
into that video. Took a lot of word.
So good.
So then when you showed it to me,
you were all excited and,
and the video CGI stuff is awesome.
Right?
But I know that you wanted me to be just,
you know,
over the top with filled with awe at
the video and I was with the visuals,
but I was, that was a lot of that
was countered by Christmas songs,
music. And so what you saw from
my reaction was actually fake,
fairly fate. There was a fair amount
of realness and there, let me tell you,
cause here, and I remember it and
I won't forget it cause you were,
cause you know,
you go a little bit insight where you
all kind of like form it where it does
like a certain thing and then it'll drop
off then, then I'll come back, whatever.
So there's this part where the certain
parts starts that I'm like, oh he's gonna,
he's gonna kind of like that
part. Right. So I'm kind of,
so I kind of look over at
you if I know super childish,
but I'm like looking at you or whatever
and you're like looking at it and then
like when that part hit and it's
Christmas music, you're like, hmm.
Like as if to say interesting
choice instead of, you know.
Anyway, so rough. We changed
the Christmas music as a result.
So bowl anyway,
one of the biggest hit video of all time.
Anyway. Yeah. So yeah, enhance
excerpts. That's what's on there.
Along with of course,
the video version of this podcast,
if you care what y'all call looks like.
Also jock was a store,
it's called Jacqueline store.
Url Is Jacqueline, store.com.
It's a website obviously.
I know not that creative,
but still cool stuff on there
and stuff is creative I think.
So go on their shirts,
hats. We even got a new hat.
It's like a flex fit now. Boom. Lot of
people been asking for that delivered.
Gladly delivered anyway, who he's
on there. Like I said, rash guards,
women's stuff, some new mugs.
You know what? I think I'm
putting the tea on there.
So if you know,
if they want to have that option to
get Jocko white tea and international,
you know, Oh yeah. I think, do
you know, just more options,
more convenient for the people call
for everybody. I think nonetheless,
a lot of stuff on there. Uh, if
you want something, get something.
Also psychological warfare,
if you didn't know what that is,
it's an album with tracks.
Jocko tracks.
I know that sounds like, okay. It's
kind of esoteric. Jocko tracks.
Was that mean here?
This is what it means.
It means it's not in him seeing nothing
like that. So in your mom, in your,
in your campaign against weakness
and we're all in the pack straight,
it's like common knowledge are they, all
of us were on the path. Like if you're,
if we're listening to this, even
me talking to you, listen to me.
We're on the path. All of us on
group now, this is inevitable,
I think for the most part. Inevitable.
Where are you going to hit?
Moments of weakness.
Sometimes you need a little help
through those moments of weakness.
Sometimes you need to just slip in those
moments of weakness and fall and be
like, I'm not doing that again. Sometimes
that's useful. You learn in my opinion,
but in those moments of weakness
where you just need a little spot,
this is what Jocko tracks or for,
so let's say your weaknesses,
not getting up early. You want to hit the
snooze switch, you want to do too tired.
I don't know. Whatever. Maybe
drink a little bit. I don't know.
So you're on the fence, you're like, I'm
gonna hit this news just for, for what?
What? What's a normal snooze? 10
minutes, nine minutes, whatever.
I don't know what I'm saying.
You have to tell me about that.
Anyway, actually it's
not fourth. The snooze,
technically it's not for hitting the
snooze, it's for going back to bed.
That's the weakness that this
particular track cause hitting this new.
This is like if you,
if you just want to hit the snooze,
you're not going to have the energy
to get up and you know, boom.
Maybe if you put it as your alarm.
Nonetheless, this is what is the track it,
it's jock.
On a specific track telling you why
you should just get up and not hit the
snooze or not staying bid. But it's
like Jocko pragmatic advice. It's good.
100% and this goes for a diet stuff.
Skipping workout stuff.
Hundred percent effectiveness,
hundred percent that's good.
Speaking of 100% if you
100% 100% guaranteed,
want to be able to deadlift 8,000
pounds minimum, you might go over that.
All you have to do is drink Jocko
tea. Is that it? Simple, bro. Okay.
And the kids are going to get sued.
Am I going to get sued for false
advertising? No, because, and here's why.
So this good. Josiah is this big
huge guy tore his bicep by the way,
a few weeks ago, maybe a few months
ago. It's been probably a few months.
And the last big guy, dead lifts, you
know, has the setup right? And, and he'll,
he'll have videos there.
I watch them just understanding what we
can and so he turns his Bicep, you know,
it happens. And so
heat, there's the video.
Actually I think this video is before
he tore the bicep. No, no it was after.
So he has his arm in a sling.
Right when you have the bicep tear.
So he drinks some Jocko
white tea with the 10 pounds.
It any smashes the tin and I'm not joking.
The actual video smashes 10 throws
the 10 dead lifts. One bad arm,
one hand. And it's like more than I
can deadlift for real in real life.
The one hand deadlift,
so boom, proof proof.
See what I'm saying by
way of Video Josiah?
Yeah, that it is. You can
get that on Amazon soon.
Very soon. We're, I
shouldn't say very soon.
Within a few weeks you're going to be
able to get readymade Jocko white tea in a
cam. We're going to put some
companies out of business.
Yeah. Cause you're going to be at
seven 11 gone. Oh you know what? Oh,
maybe I'll have the sugar filled thing
over here and it will make me feel like,
like, like high on a sugar high
for about 15 minutes and I want to,
they don't want to fall asleep and be
lame and I'll be getting diabetes or I can
have drove away change and let this
car. So anyways, yeah, that's common.
That's common.
I'll let you all know when that's out.
Hey books way the warrior kid series
shows the path of hard work
and discipline to kids.
Book two is out now it's called Mark's
mission. Teach your kids to be stronger,
faster, smarter, more confident.
Teach them to have better
perspective on other people.
How to handle verbal
and physical bullying.
Yeah. Teach them to be a warrior
kids and speaking to more your kids.
If you want to support a warrior kid,
go to Irish oaks ranch.com and get some
or your kids soap made by Aiden who's 13
years old, owns his own business
chocolate. So yeah, he makes Jocko soap.
It's good to use if
you want to stay clean,
don't forget about the discipline
equals freedom field manual.
And you know what this is. This is good.
Read, read. Just read one section a day.
Okay.
Legit. Read one section a day that
will legitimately keep you on the path.
Try it. You're right. Yeah.
If you want to listen to one
track a day instead of read it,
cause maybe do it in the car
or whatever is not on audible.
It's on MP3, the disparate calls,
freedom field, manual, iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
wherever you can listen to MP three
s of course there's leadership book,
extreme ownership,
combat leadership and how to apply it
to your business and life over a million
copies of that have sold.
That's a lot.
And is not because we did
a big advertising campaign.
There's not because we took out an
advertisement in the Superbowl series. No,
it's because of word of mouth. That's
why people read it because it works.
So get that for your business in life
and actually if you want to now order the
follow on book two extreme ownership.
It's called the dichotomy of leadership
life and I just finished writing it.
This book will,
it's really going to help leaders.
I can't wait to get it out
there into people's hands.
One of the hardest things to do as
leaders is find a balance between all the
dichotomies of leadership. And this
will help you do that. Order it now.
Otherwise the same thing's gonna happen.
Publishers won't have a copy for you
and you're gonna be mad and I'll be mad.
That's the way it works.
If you need direct leadership support
for your team, contact echelon front,
which is my leadership consulting
company, it's me, it's Leif Babin.
Get to JP to know Dave Burke.
Our website is Ashkelon front.com and
we solve problems through leadership.
That's what we do. And of course
there's the muster leadership seminar.
By the way,
zero zero five in Washington DC sold out.
So if you want to come to a monster,
you can't come to that one.
You've got to wait until October 17th
and 18th in San Francisco, California.
That is the next muster.
And also at the muster,
we will not be backstage in the green
room clearing our minds in an isolation
float tank.
We will not be doing that.
We will be with you out there the whole
time. Talking, answering questions,
working out, eating, rolling Jujitsu,
everything come to the muster pragmatic
leadership training for people that are
leaders,
people that aspire to be leaders and
also on top of that for current military,
law enforcement, firefighters,
paramedics, other first responders,
we have roll call one
September 21st Dallas,
Texas.
It's one day that's about
leadership in dynamic environments.
You can register to that one
as well@extremeownershipa.com
and until we are
together live at one of those events,
whether it's the monster or it's the roll
call or it's the immersion camp up in
Maine.
If you want to communicate with us and
you can do that via the interwebs where
we're cruising big time.
I am Jocko Willink.
Echo is at echocharles and
also military outreach USA,
which is the organization that's run by
General Luker Yama if you want to follow
that.
They are on Twitter at at mill
outreach USA at mill outreach USA.
They also have their Facebook page,
which is military outreach USA.
And if you didn't catch the
website the first time around,
military outreach usa.org
great organization led by a great man,
General James Mooky Yama.
And again we thank him for his service
sacrifice and what he has done for our
great nation and what he continues to do.
And I thank him for coming on the podcast
to share his lessons learned and also
thanks to his son Jay for connecting us.
Truly appreciate it.
It was an amazing experience for me to
talk through lessons learned that he
learned from one of my mentors and one
of my heroes, Colonel David Hackworth.
So thank you both and thanks to all the
men and women in uniform out there doing
your duty,
holding the line,
protecting our flag and our freedom
and to the police and law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics and all the other first
responders that protect us day and night
while we're here at home.
Thank you for your vigilance
and to everyone else that is listening.
The fact you were factory workers and
dry wall hangers and bankers and brokers
and waiters and waitresses and cooks
and dishwashers to business owners and
investors than software designers and
CEOs and salespeople to everyone out there
doing your best to do your best.
Think about those hardcore rock condos
that fought and think about those
hardcore Reccondo is
that didn't come home.
Remember them.
Okay.
And for them, don't let
up. Don't slow down.
Don't allow any slack.
Uh,
keep getting after it.
Summer til next time.
This is echo and Jocko.
Okay.
Out.